Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Die neueste ich habe gehört linksradikale Kräfte wollen dich aus der Metaebene drängen.
Dann gehe ich in die Politik.
Buch Netzpolitik Nummer 275 vom Schicksalstag der deutschen dem 9. November 2018 Programm Mauerfall und jetzt auch noch.
Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Bundespolitik so siehts aus.
9. November eine Bombe Überleitung ein Tag ist es wirklich ist es.
Super formuliert.
Es ist.
Habe dieser du voll unter Kontrolle ihr merkt das schon.
Eine Überraschung.
Zum Motto Motto des 35 C3 der 35 C3 hat ja gestern seinen ersten.
Offiziellen öffentlichen Vorverkaufs Tag gehabt übrigens kann ich bei der Gelegenheit direkt noch sagen wann die weiteren sind um,
euch daran zu erinnern solltet ihr gestern keinen Erfolg gehabt haben wie ich übrigens ich habe auch kein Erfolg gehabt ich habe da wirklich ich war.
Hast du noch im dizlek.
In der cue war ich Position 6600.
Alpha 6500.
Und hast du auch keinen Erfolg gehabt.
Nee keiner Volker.
Aber das ist die sagt hier dass ein paar Leute sitzen die einfach die Tür würde ich sagen ich gucke mal weg weil wir einfach jeden Scheiß mitmachen der Internet gerade abgeht weißt du.
Nein man muss ja auch ein bisschen schauen was du.
Wie ist das denn so und naja.
Aber gar kein Weg wird mit Muster Englisch einfach Manicure ab.
Und wenn es doch mal eben wieder aufgeht Radio Tricks die Büchsen kaputt zu dürfen da sind wir dabei hat nicht funktioniert.
Hat aber nicht funktioniert nee da müssen schon andere kommen oder was können wir später noch.
Mister mit besser ungültig Geschütz auffahren also,
11. November um 14 Uhr und 21 Uhr November um 21 Uhr sind die nächsten Termine,
brauche ich eigentlich raus heute ist wir haben ja jetzt auch das Motto bekanntgegeben des Kongresses in der Mall das Motto,
das Congress wollte ich vielleicht hierzu müssen noch ein bisschen erklären weil ich natürlich die Gelegenheit nutzen möchte hier Lust auf dieses Motto zu machen und zwar.
Ist es ja eigentlich weltweit Sohn das früher war alles besser.
So zum Leitgedanken der weltweiten politischen Kultur geworden ist also Türkei Italien Amerika Großbritannien Ungarn Brasilien in Deutschland noch nicht an der Regierung aber in regierungsfeindliche
Parteien,
hast du über also dieses dieses Versprechen einfacher Lösungen die uns ihr wieder zurück geh den Weg zurück in die Vergangenheit zeigen boy.
Großbritannien Karte auch in der Liste.
Natürlich Atala.
Ja ja das ist total super Angel.
Wird es in Wien und ich habe das schon damals bei der Wahl Donald Trumps gesagt jetzt zwei Jahre her ist die zeigen den Weg zurück in eine Vergangenheit die ist schon damals nicht gab.
Beyma natürlich zu seiner Wahl sagen kann dass ab dem Moment wirklich früher alles besser war.
Also make früher alles war früher war alles besser erkennen und,
führen den Weg zurück in eine Vergangenheit die Sylvie schon damals nicht gab
make America great again ne wir müssen wieder leistung muss sich wieder lohnen als wenn Paket macht so gewesen wäre meine lieben Freunde und.
Ich finde das sehr.
Psychiater psychologische Perspektive sehr schön wie das auch funktioniert ja denn du hast.
Der Trick ist eigentlich relativ einfach die Zukunft ist immer ungewiss die hast du nicht erlebt ja und dir Angst vor der Zukunft zu machen ist relativ einfach vor allem wenn die Zukunft Veränderung ist und die Veränderung wird in der Regel etwas sein was du noch nicht kennst,
so ich bin mit meinem bisherigen.
Weil ich fast immer.
Mit meinem Dealer mein mein bisheriges Leben ist mir relativ vertraut und auch wenn das,
schlecht war der wenn es der negative Seiten gab dann habe ich mich immer mit den Widrigkeiten arrangieren können und,
wenn ich in in der Retrospektive ist auch immer alles gar nicht so schlimm,
Bibis vielleicht in der in der Gegenwart war oder damals als es noch Zukunft war ja und,
genau daran diese diese Erinnerung sind aber natürlich auch,
verklärt er ist ganz normal so wird niemand unterstellen dass er seine Erinnerung nicht im Griff hätte aber Erinnerung werden vom Hirn genauso verarbeitet wie das Erlebte und da gibt's eben genausowenig Objektivität.
Und Sofa so ist auch das erinneren das erinnern im Gehirn ein dynamischer Prozess Fazit was will ich sagen.
Wir sind wir können uns sehr viel einfacher eine Vergangenheit glorifizieren als eine Zukunft,
weil die Zukunft ungewiss ist und die Vergangenheiten meinen wir zu kennen deswegen ist sie so ganzen rückwärtsgewandten,
also in der Zeit rückwärts gewandten Appelle sind etwas was unserem Gehirn erstmal so eine Sicherheit zu geriert also genaue ich will wieder zurück zu früher weil das kenne ich das ist das Vertraute.
Wissen was ich meine das zu kennen das wird ja dann auch noch mal verklärt und dann war es eigentlich auch gar nicht so.
War vielleicht gar nicht so aber.
Meistens nicht früher eigentlich alles ziemlich beschissen gewesen der Früh.
Früher war auch scheiße das muss man einfach mal sagen.
Früher war auch scheiße und daran darauf bezugnehmend.
Haben wir jetzt das Motto gewählt für den Kongress refreshing memories und das ist natürlich wie so häufig,
ein Wortspiel und bezieht einmal oder hat einmal den Bezug zu erinnerungen
auffrischen also es ist an der Zeit sich mal daran zu erinnern die es früher
war unser Gesellschaften war nie perfekt wir müssen die weiterentwickeln Fortschritt ist ein Weg ins Ungewisse und vielleicht auch ne Erinnerung auffrischen an
Zeiten vor vielleicht genau 100 Jahren Zeiten vor 60 Jahren.
Schicksalstag Gehalt.
Schicksals Tage wie den 9. November und andere in Deutschland wo auch häufig irgendwo eine Gruppe,
eine Rolle gespielt hat die Männer relativ einfachen Lösungen Zustand von früher glorifiziert hat und den wiederherstellen wollte,
und das hat uns eigentlich nie weit gebracht also daran müssen wir unsere Erinnerungen ein bisschen auffrischen und gleichzeitig heißt ja refreshing memories auch erfrischende erinnerungen also schöne schöne Erinnerungen die.
Wir alle glaube ich in den Kongress Situationen sammeln die uns auch ewig Kraft geben weiterhin finde Zukunft.
Wir schaffen die und wir bauen uns da unsere eigene Welt und jetzt müssen wir diese schöne eigene Welt dazu,
bauen dass die das ganze Jahr über so ist und wir nicht immer nur in unsere erfrischenden erinnerungen uns flüchten auf diesem Kongress,
und dann geht's natürlich auch was ich sehr schön finde was das Ganze zum schönen Motto für so ein Hacker Kongress macht was wir,
Kultur ist
das Auffrischen von Erinnerungen du erzählst ihm wie deine Geschichten weiter und deinem oder Märchen oder deine Gründungsmythen der Republik oder sowas naja mich ein bisschen dieser Aborigine Kultur mal beschäftigt er wird ja auch in die ihnen Geschichten
ihre Kultur weitererzählen und auch nur das in in diesen Geschichten weil die ihre Kultur in diesen Geschichten übermitteln die nicht nieder.
Bist du dir aber nicht nur die Aborigines haben das getan haben.
Genau weil ich jetzt wirklich auf das erzählen weil India nimm viele andere Kulturen machen das dann mit irgendwelchen Büchern mit denen in der Hand dann nachher Leute in andere Länder mal stehen und Kriege anfangen,
aber es gibt also Kultur ist das weitererzählen und das Auffrischen dass das Weitergeben von Erinnerungen und leistet im Computer,
biz,
in den in den Flipflops hin und herschieben ist es genauso das refreshing von memories heise.de der der Arbeitsspeicher wird ebenso refreshed und das fanden wir irgendwie ganz schön.
Damit er überhaupt funktioniert.
Damit er überhaupt funktioniert muss ein memory.
Und nicht zu vergessen um noch mal das mit der Kultur und das noch mal mit der Kultur aufzugreifen nehme dir zwar kein einziger Kopiervorgang sind.
Damit dann überhaupt Neues zu schaffen.
Und wenn du wenn du so alt bist wie ich Tim wenn du so also wenn du schon so alt bist wichtig.
Wenn ich mal so alt wäre wie du na ja da ich erst so dauerhaft jung bin.
Weißt du doch was das.
Können wir das eigentlich nicht passieren.
Du bist ja auch hier wie dieser Checker Typ ne hat gesagt das nicht mitbekommen.
Ich weiß es jetzt gerade nicht was.
Spiele der der hat früher so eine sender gemacht tschakka du schaffst es
und jetzt hat er sich der solange getackert bis der der Überzeugung ist dass er nicht 69 ist sondern 49 und klagt jetzt in den Niederlanden während er klagt gegen sein Geburtsdatum.
Das wirkliche blau.
Und er sagt ihr das irgendwie sein Wohlbefinden eben jetzt gesteigert wäre wenn 20 Jahre aus seinem Leben getilgt werden und ist auch im Gegenzug bereit für die 20 Jahre Rentenansprüche dann zu verzichten.
Er fand sein Argument ist ja auch geil warum das sein muss ne weil er ja sonst wie keine Chance mehr auf Kinder hat weil er da irgendwie gedisst wird.
Genau und da will ich dann will ich den jungen Mann empfehlen,
also man kann ja sein der Junge weint er der junge Mann hätte sich echt mal bei Barbara Streisand er kündigen müssen wie man sein wahres Alter geheim hält ja kein Mensch wusste dass es den überhaupt noch gibt keine Sau hat sich für dessen Alter interessiert,
bis der angefangen hat wie die gegen den niederländischen statt zu klagen und sein Geburtsdatum ändern zu lassen so einer bist du auch oder was ne.
Genau jetzt.
Mit mir ich weiß dass mit mir meine ewige Jugend nicht nehmen kann.
Du kennst doch so Situation was auch tatsächlich.
Früher einmal das Weitergeben von von memories für eine Nacht war der mit dem 4 fach CD Brenner 20 Minuten oder wie ist der Scheiße gedauert hat da konnte man wirklich von einer kulturpraxis.
CD-Brenner ich bitte dich ich habe noch stundenlang neben floppy disk and Taps Taps Taps kopiert.
Das auch aber nur meine floppy disk aber eine Floppy Disk zu kopieren ok das hat lange gedauert.
300 Bit pro Sekunde in Realtime.
Hattest du keinen hier.
30 tschuldigung.
Kyra ich hatte einen schnell Kopierer also high speed dubbing hieß das dann hat er auf beiden auf auf abspiele Band.
Ja ihr in den Neunzigern ja tut's gut wir hatten high speed dubbing.
Erinner Lotion das wird unsere Informationsgesellschaft revolutionieren die Welt rückt näher zusammen Hauptsache ist Heimat keiner unsere Kassetten.
Wollte mich aus.
Und jetzt stehen wir vor dem Weg Lucifer fassungslos in einer Welt wo inzwischen die Wissenschaft angegriffen wird den ganzen Tag von alternativen Fakten und fake-news geredet wird und Populisten allen möglichen Scheiß,
behaupten und hin und irgendwie hat er nicht damit durchkommen und da müssen wir einfach mal.
Auch unsere eigenen Erinnerungen wachrütteln und somit war ich sehr begeistert von diesem Motto das eben natürlich so eine sehr kritische Perspektive auch wieder zeigt aber eben auch kulturelle.
Referenzen in diese Hacker Szene hat und außerdem eben auch glaube ich sehr den so dieses Gefühl was die Menschen in dieser Community für die Veranstaltungen haben,
auch ein bisschen einfängt.
Ich hoffe es gibt auch irgendwo ein erfrischungsstand auf dem Kongress wo man dann auch mal so sein.
Dein RAM abgeben Kanne kriegt eine Gurkenmaske.
Der sein Hirn sein Hirn Hirn refreshment machen kann.
Da gibt's glaube ich genug Leute die direkt treffen.
Nightblue.
Da gibt's auf jeden Fall auch Angebote Tim.
Memory Refresher II.
Bleiben Sie bitte auf dem vorgezeichneten Fadenwürmer please stay on the path.
Ja aber wird ein bisschen vom Wege abgekommen ist unser Dauer Verfassungsschutzpräsident.
Der Brauch auf jeden Fall auch man memory refresh.
Der hat allem seinen spiel ein wenig seine Karten ein wenig genauer sagen seit Blatt überreizt.
Oder so könnte man das formulieren,
ja wir hatten ja jeder in den letzten Sendungen noch mehrfach ich glaube auch in der letzten hast du das mit mir ich kann mich nicht so richtig erinnern was du mir alles erzählt hast der letzte der noch nicht weiß gar nicht warum auf jeden Fall.
Neben der Spur.
Auf jeden Fall,
Maßen so ein Abschiedsbrief Vortrag Rede gehalten.
Die war aber eher so Verfassungsschutz intern aber nicht intern genug um nicht dann auch eine gewisse Zirkulation zur finde.
Er hat die ins in ins Internet stellen lassen sein Rede Manuskript.
Und offenbar sind die Dinge dann doch nicht so geheim dass ist am Kreisel die ist und ja da hat er dann eine interessante Verschwörungstheorie,
aufgestellten der vente linksradikale Kräfte in der SPD,
was natürlich ein vollkommen unfassbarer Vorwurf ist kannst du das vorstellen Linke in der SPD.
Seine seine Äußerung ist die Medien sowie Grüne und Linke Politiker die sich durch mich bei ihrer falsch Berichterstattung ertappt fühlten forderten daraufhin meiner Entlassung aus meiner Sicht war dies für Linksklick Hradec
radikale Kräfte der SPD mein Körper will das gar nicht sagen weil das Foto memory refresh error.
Die von vornherein dagegen waren eine Koalition mit der CDU CSU reinzugehen der willkommen da anders um einen Bruch der Regierungskoalition zu provozieren da ich in Deutschland als Kritiker einer ideal
idealistischen naiven und linken Ausländer und Sicherheitspolitik bekannt bin war dies für mich
für meine politischen Gegner und für einige Medien auch ein Anlass um mich aus dem Amt zu drängen.
Meist erst vom JUSO Vorsitzenden vom Thron gestoßen worden habe Hände wusste ich gar nicht dass ihr so viel Einfluss haben.
Linksradikale Kräfte in der SPD.
Das interessant.
Wo die wo die überall lauern ne.
Können sich auf ihre Wahlplakate demnächst drauf schreiben jetzt auch mit linksradikalen Griff.
Also jetzt ist die Frage wurde gefeuert weil linksradikale Kräfte in der SPD einfach so dermaßen ab vom vom Pfad der Tugend ist dass sie sagt nee muss mal lieber,
zum Arzt oder wie ich glaube er wurde gefeuert weil oder wie es auch begründet wurde mit dieser Aktion er hat ja vorher sich irgendwie,
gegenüber Seehofer gerechtfertigt für seine Äußerungen und hat das Eis der zurückgerudert ursprünglich hat ja gesagt hier Medien und so weiter,
dann wurde gesagt also er hat ja gesagt hier falsch Berichterstattung und Sohn in Hamm.
Haben der Innenausschuss und Seehofer und die die die links grün versifften Medien Lügenpresse gesagt wir würden gerne sehen,
hast du irgendeinen Beleg für deine Äußerungen dann musste er zugestehen dass das nicht der Fall ist und musste zurückrudern auf,
ja aber es wäre gut gewesen wenn die anderen auch erstmal geprüft hätten bevor sie im Mund aufmachen und dann hat er Seehofer gesagt da ok,
das mache ich auch regelmäßig Fresse auf und nichts dahinter ist ok ne stelle ich mich vor habe ich Sympathie für und jetzt,
hat er eben quasi seine seine Verschwörungstheorien dort wiederholt auch wieder behaupten von falsch Berichterstattung geredet,
die sich durch mich bei ihrer falsch Berichterstattung ertappt fühlten,
ja was eben er behauptet immer noch dabei hätte eine falsche Berichterstattung stattgefunden und dafür musste er dann natürlich jetzt das sehe ich ebenfalls so von Seehofer,
höchstpersönlich.
Komplett gegangen werden.
Also ganz klar und da da bin ich auch bei Seehofers erklär und ich habe mir die Pressekonferenz dazu angeschaut und Seehofer sagt ja auch ich stelle mich erstmal vor meine Leute und das,
da zitiert er ein Motiv was ihn ehren würde da.
Und wenn er dann sagt wenn aber meine Mitarbeiter mir gegenüber.
Dann nicht mehr loyal sind und quasi Abbitte leisten das dann dem aber wieder,
das Sprechen dann muss ich diese Leute muss ich dafür sorgen dass sie etwa den Ruhestand kommen,
das hat ja dann eben mit bitte an den Bundestag einem Bundespräsidenten den Maßen zu gehen.
Seit dieser Staatssekretär von der SPD der einzige der Ministerium noch da war mittlerweile eigentlich wieder zurückgeholt worden.
Ja der wurde der durfte er dann bleiben klar ja und dann denkt.
Ist alles gut.
Ja alles gut mein.
Wenn wir den nie wieder sehen.
Wäre schön gewesen wenn Seehofer einfach direkt mal mitgegangen wäre weil natürlich war das nicht klug von Seehofer diese Sache so blöd eskalieren zu lassen ich kann mir auch vorstellen wie,
naja also lassen wir das aber das wäre natürlich eigentlich jetzt schon nett gewesen Seehofer auch direkt mit los zu sein,
das sehen wir vielleicht dieses Wochenende dann was er wohnt wo man ihn vielleicht noch mal loswerden könnte
aber schön ist das Master und Doktor also könnte sich durchaus vorstellen jetzt in die Politik zu gehen und dann wird aus dieser deiner aus unserer Initialen Freude wir sind diesen wahnsinnigen los einfach nur noch eine bittere Furcht weil die jetzt,
einen wenn der in die Politik geht dann wird er das nicht in der CDU sinnvoll tun können.
Na ja jetzt schon gesagt er will in der CDU bleiben.
Ja das hat also Thilo Sarrazin ist auch in der SPD geblieben,
es gibt häufig Menschen die in einer völlig ungeeigneten Organisation für Sie sich verhaften und dann dort,
gleich mal für für Stress und Unruhe sorgen und das kann natürlich einen Maßen,
in einer CDU unter Umständen noch sehr viel effizienter tun als er ist in einer AFD machen könnte ja insofern kann ich mir sogar sehr gut vorstellen dass er.
In der CDU bleibt er wird aufgrund seines Namens Gehör finden.
Und wenn ihm sagen wir mal die die halbwegs informierte Presse dieses Gehör verweigert dann wird er das eben in den Rechtsdrall Medien,
bekommen und da wird er als Fürsprecher von AFD Positionen natürlich als ehemaliger Verfassungsschützer und Mitglied der CDU noch.
Bessere Wirkung entfalten können als der aus einer Regierungskoalition geschasste Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz der nun zur AFD übergegangen ist insofern glaube ich der tatsächlich dass er
um seiner eigenen Wirkung wählen in der CDU bleibt.
Von dort aus weiterhin seine kruden und extremistischen Thesen verurteilt barfbar verbreitet.
Und dann haben wir den Salat und dann hat die dann haben wir einen AFD,
nahen Menschen der,
viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen kann Mia und das ist das ist tatsächlich eine Gefahr die ich da sehe vor allem wenn jemand,
als ehemaliger Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz ganz offensichtlich einen Trump Schonbezug zu Fakten hat.
Das ist,
schlecht bei der in Zukunft behaupten kann was er will und Leute sagen und wenn sollte sagen hallo Herr Maassen wir würden gerne sehen dann wird er sein da kann ich leider nicht zu äußern ich unterliege wie Sie wissen der Vertraulichkeit,
meine meiner ist ehemaligen Amtes aus dem ich von der linksgrünen Kräften in der SPD gedrängt wurde und das wird das ist eine gefährliche Figur und der wird gefährlich bleiben.
Rechtsextremismus warum sie würden aber nicht schon früher darauf gekommen.
Exkrement sage ich öfters statt Experiment.
Ja
Rechtsextremistische Kräfte.
Naja.
Ihr berichtete über einem Security Vorfall.
Ja da bleiben wir direkt bei weit ramsha Wahrheitsfindung.
Wir haben die Sendung letzte Woche ja aufgenommen,
quasi zu dem Zeitpunkt als Thorsten und Martin gerade erst veröffentlicht hatten die Forschungsergebnisse zu einer kritischen Beugung der Plattform Wiwi.
Wir erinnern uns die haben da die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung Außerkraftsetzung können sie haben Patienten Daten auslesen können,
und sie haben diese Schwachstellen gemeldet und es war schon relativ schnell klar dass diese,
da verantwortlichen Personen sagen wir mal nicht unbedingt den,
aufrichtigsten Umgang mit diesem Schwachstellen pflegen würden sowas wie ne um komische Verlängerungen bitten mit der Veröffentlichung.
Und gehen welche SS war relativ relativ klar dass sie ja dann auch z.b. ist geschafft haben erstmal alle Sicherheitslücken zu,
negieren in der Berichterstattung wurde sehr viel übernommen und das war tatsächlich erschreckend ja,
angebliche Sicherheitslücken die haben's geschafft,
die Berichterstattung dahin zu spinnen dass diese Sicherheitslücken irgendwie angeblich oder oder kontrovers oder sonstiges werden und das ist natürlich echt krass.
Das ist wirklich krass oder habe ich mich gefragt wie machen die das ne also die kriegen das hin und sagen wir mal so,
aus mehreren von mehreren Journalisten und Redaktionen.
Hörte man dann das die Anrufe bekommen haben teilweise sogar schon vor der Veröffentlichung überhaupt.
Und teilweise nach deren eigenen Veröffentlichungen dass ich dort also Personen die,
von Vivi waren oder wie sich vielmehr herausstellt von Vivi beauftragt waren.
Journalisten gewendet haben und denen sogenannte Korrektur bitten ähnlich übrigens wie Maßen das ja auch gemacht hat bei Berichterstattung über sein Versagen.
Zur Korrektur bitten haben zukommen lassen und da sind 116 spätestens bei netzpolitik.org bei den falschen gelandet.
Was haben sie auch sollte mal jemand dran lassen sollen der sich da auskennt.
Erstens würde es sehr sehr schön dann haben sie behauptet sie hätten ja alle Schwachstellen binnen 24 Stunden geschlossen,
ja und diese diese die Meldungen von von
Thorsten Martin Baba Monate her oder oder Wochen her tschuldigung 3 3 oder 4 Wochen vorher hatten die diese Schwachstellen gemeldet und haben wir darauf gewartet dass Vivi sagen kann ok diese Schwachstelle sind die war der so kritisch,
Stift,
sie nicht veröffentlicht werden konnten solange sie noch da waren das heißt Wi-Fi musste fixen und erst dann konnte konnten Thorsten und Martin veröffentlichen.
Und jetzt sagen sie hätten alles binnen 24 Stunden geschlossen verträgt sich natürlich schwer mit einer signierten GP signierten nicht fällt sparen E-Mail,
in der die spezifisch um eine Verlängerung des responsible disclosure Prozesses bitten weil nämlich ursprünglich gesagt wurde okay wir veröffentlich in 14 Tagen und sie da gesagt haben könnt ihr nicht irgendwie noch mal 14 Tage um drauf machen ja,
das heißt natürlich schwierig wenn du selber eine signierte E-Mail sendest in der du meine Verlängerung bitte weil du schreibst um das zu beheben brauchen wir länger nachher aber bei den Medien anrufst und denen behauptet den gegenüber behauptet wird es alles in 24 Stunden
behoben weiteren weiterhin hatte.
Thorsten gesagt eine Verkettung zahlreicher kleinerer Probleme der Videoplattform hat letztlich dazu geführt dass der Schutz der Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung ausgehebelt werden konnte das ist eben das,
Auslesen von Daten anderer per die nicht für dich bestimmt waren das sind große Problem war überhaupt er euch steht überhaupt nichts also war einfach Fakt.
Oder kommentierte Wiwi einfach nur falsch haben wir auch letzte Woche schon drüber gesprochen
interessanterweise widersprechen sie damit aber ihren eigenen Angaben aus ihrer eigenen Stellungnahme wo sie nämlich sagen dass der RSA Schlüssel von den Endgeräten der Ärzte verwendet werden konnte,
und sagen dass es eben sie dann immer der Konten fragt mente aber nie der ganze Datensatz entfernt wurden,
also dann komm doch weitere Details was ich sehr übel auch fand dass sie sich immer auf Testuser bezogen haben sein ja ja die konnten nur Daten von Testuser extrahieren das natürlichen interessante Falle,
weil würde was Zero hingehen und dem widersprechen da wird sie sich ja einer Straftat bezichtigen.
Denn das Extrahieren von echten Patientendaten wäre ja jetzt nicht gut gewesen.
Und da haben wir im Paragraphen für in Deutschland unter denen die sich schuldig machen würden interessanterweise die Testuser waren aber von Mod Zero und nicht von den
also echt eine eine ein Handling was sowas von skuril ist und dann bekommt am Ende Thorsten noch einen anruf ja
von einem Herrn Torsten Rössing,
da wurde mir einiges klar der nämlich dann fragte sie ja sagen Sie doch mal können sie mir dann noch mal ein bisschen was zu ihrem Vorgehen sagen haben sie da auch Brute-Force-Angriffe getestet.
Und sagt dann ja das wäre also kann ich ihn ja nur sein der gibt ja auch juristische Probleme wenn Sie das gemacht hätten ja also mit anderen Worten hier sind noch so eine so eine Drohung,
modern hier wieder so dieses juristische Mitch schwer bei den Redaktionen natürlich genauso ja also da möchten wir Sie darauf aufmerksam machen dass sie ja verpflichtet sind unsere Gegendarstellungen zu verpflichten und dass sie sich strafbar machen wenn sie falsch Behauptungen,
erheben und das natürlich klar nur bei einer Falschbehauptung ist das so deswegen hat er neben auch netzpolitik.org alle deren Behauptungen noch einmal.
Fein säuberlich säuberlich widerlegt und da fragt man sich natürlich wer ist eigentlich dieser Torsten Rössing ein Krisen Kommunikator.
Der der sich damit also der dessen Dienstleistung ist
dass sie erfahrene und spezialisierte Krisenteams bereitstellen die die Situation dann übernehmen Fragen beantworten dabei helfen ist Schuss zu priorisieren und strategische Entscheidungen treffen.
Und dann sagen sie hätten einen Netzwerk von extern stakeholders mit vielen Hintergründen und also aus verschiedenen Hintergründen die ihm dabei helfen die Krisen,
in eine Chance umzuwandeln indem sie eben offenbar dann auch noch bei Journalisten und,
Sicherheitsforscher anrufen und den relativ unverhohlen drohen ich habe ehrlich gesagt den ein und der scheint er außen in der andere in einer anderen Branche als Krisenmanager bisher tätig zu sein.
Das ist schon echt interessant ich find's auch interessant dass dieses Unternehmen wie sie nicht in der Lage war dieses Ding einfach mal aufrichtig selber zu händeln ja wenn also wenn es darum geht dass du Sicherheit,
relevante da,
nicht vernünftig gehandelt hast dann kannst Du eben damit aufrichtig umgehen und das ist es auch so einer Situation eine Chance zu machen nicht aber zu sagen Kacke wir haben Scheiße gebaut und wir brauchen jetzt jemanden der das für uns übernimmt,
der das für uns geklärt wir können wir Vertrauen anderen Leuten mehr dieses Problem zu lösen und ehrlich gesagt ist für mich auch allein schon die dass das engagieren eines Krisenmanager.
Die die Erkenntnis dass man selber nicht kann und da bin ich also bin ich nur.
Erneut darin bestärkt dass das wirklich sehr sehr.
Schlechte Idee ist diesen Menschen seine Daten anzuvertrauen weil das eben keinen verantwortungsbewussten Umgang mit der Ei
zeig uns das hat ja bei dem citeo also dem verantwortlichen
dieses Unternehmens sich auch schon an anderen Stellen gezeigt wo der Mann in Verantwortung stand ja n26.
Ist da nur eines der Beispiele wo der gute Christian rebernik auch schon seiner Verantwortung nicht gerecht geworden ist.
Auf dieser Webseite von sagen Tour als Kunde gelistet zu werden.
Wir hatten alle die Kacke am dampfen und kam nicht mehr klar.
Ja das ist halt das ist halt interessant und selbstverständlich wir sind ein führendes Beratungsunternehmen für reputations Krisen das margeit die hatten keine Reporter totgesagten eine Sicherheits Krise.
Da ist da hängt natürlich eine reputations Krise dran.
Sie haben selber so gesehen.
Mit unserer Arbeit schützen wir die Wahrnehmung ihres Unternehmens bei allen relevanten Stakeholdern aus Politik Gesellschaft Medien und Wirtschaft durch strategische Argumentation,
gewinnen wir die Köpfe dieser Stakeholder und prägen so die öffentliche Meinung in ihrem Sinne wie er nutzt Instrumente aus der PR und der Argumentationstheorie und Ihr Unternehmen bei erklärungsbedürftigen und kontroverse Themen langfristig stabil in ihrem Umfeld zu positionieren
unser Ziel ist es dass sie auch in kritischen Situation die Oberhand behalten alter Vater ey.
Wenn du also ich sehe ich würde sagen wenn du soweit bist dass du dich an solche Leute wendest dann,
hast du wirklich eine Krise und das wird dann eine Krise wenn du einen Krisenmanager bestellst du und die hatten eine.
Naja also ich meine ich sage mal so ich will das jetzt nicht so ein Persi
verdammt können wir auch durchaus cinarin vorstellen mein Unternehmen sind nicht immer nur eine Person und einer Haltung ne kann auch durchaus sein dass die Altenheim Unternehmen einfach durch
das vollkommen deathfest spuren verschiedener Mitarbeiter einfach irgendwann mal die Sache komplett aus der Hand geglitten ist und du sehr wohl,
eine Position darstellen kannst die auch,
Zauber einer bestimmten Wahrheit entspricht das muss ja nicht unbedingt immer bedeuten mit bei uns ist alles braune wir versuchen jetzt irgendwie die Sache öffentlich mit Lack zuweilen auch sehr gut andersrum laufen von daher Oma jetzt mal hier auch nicht
zu sehr auf die Kacke hauen allerdings.
Bei denen bist du offenbar bei dem falschen.
Dieses Wiwi Projekt hat sich damit sicherlich nicht unbedingt Jacen Gefallen getan.
Ich möchte auch ganz kurz sein du kannst also im Rahmen meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit Manager ich ja vielleicht auch mal eine Krise.
Und diese Krisen.
Kannst du eben so managen dass das irgendwie aufrichtig und ordentlich ist ja Schwachstellen beseitigen die richtigen Schritte einleiten,
aufrichtig kommunizieren oder du kannst dich an Torsten Rössing wenden der dann die Leute bedroht.
Das sind und in bestimmten Situationen ist das auch notwendig ja sagen wir mal du bist eine Gruppierung,
aus der organisierten Kriminalität und du gerätst in eine Krise dann ist drohen,
unter Umständen eine valide Strategie na du willst einfach auch dass dein Krisenherd weißt dass dein Arm beispielsweise auch bis in den Knast reicht.
Ja Stichwort da kannst du nicht weg,
unter unter der willst du dann also diese Form von Krisenmanagement gibt es auch die ist nur wenn du Gesundheitsdaten gelegt hast einfach nicht die richtige.
So natürlich hätte Vivi diese Krise auch durchaus mit Hilfe eines wie du sagt Krisenmanager korrekt pennen können,
der in geholfen hätte da das zu tun wozu sie sich offenbar nicht in der Lage fühlen nämlich aufrichtig mit ihrem eigenen ihren eigenen Fehlern umzugehen.
Und ihren Ruf als vertrauenswürdiges Unternehmen irgendeiner Form nicht durch falsch Behauptungen und Ignoranz und Drohung zu festigen,
das wäre die richtige Lösung gewesen hätten sie mich gefragt hätte ich ihn vielleicht auch dazu geraten.
Naja ich berate halt einfach weiterhin die organisierte Kriminalität und da habe ich wenigstens nichts mit Gesundheit dazu tun.
Unserer Kenntnis nach noch keinen Krisenmanager eingeschaltet hat der Wahlleiter des schönen Bundeslandes Hessen,
auch wenn es durchaus eine kleine Krise zu vermelden gibt die ist vielleicht nicht so groß,
aber wir nähern uns Landtagswahl ist ja gerade vor zwei Wochen gelaufen in Hessen und in zwei Wochen die anderen und,
dabei kam es wohl zu Problemen bei der Übermittlung der Wahlergebnisse,
ist das gedacht hatten wir das Thema nicht hier schonmal.
Absolut denn denn genau Hessen genau Wahl in Hessen war der ganze Anfangspunkt der pc-wahl Geschichte ja also genau dieses Land.
Beteiligten.
Genau also gleiche Beteiligten bei Wi-Fi da hatte Martin damals angefangen sich umzuschauen.
Und der Rest ist Geschichte den haben wir hier im Logbuch ausführlich erklärt.
Genau können wir mal verlinken.
Zugehaltenen haben wir den schon aus.
General Vortrag Reiten und Fahren der komplette Sendung der Bundespolitik.
Nur wenn dieses Thema naja was war damals ein bisschen die Essence na ja ihr verwendet da irgendwie komische Software und bei der Wahl Übermittlung
könnte es dann zu Turbulenzen führen und das mitten in der Außendarstellung dazu führen dass man euren kompletten Prozess ein wenig anzweifelt putzige ist dass das ja dann
in der Folge auch zeigen die Konsequenz hatte das diese automatische Übermittlung mit PC war da nicht durchgeführt werden sollte bei dieser Wahl sondern dass das Ganze händisch Erfolg spricht die mit soweit habe ich jetzt verstanden ich bin mir noch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher aber ich denke die meisten
aus zählt also die meisten Ergebnisse aus den Wahlkreisbüros sind also von den Wahlbezirken per Telefon übermittelt worden,
wundern mit einer Software,
händisch erfasst oder sollst du mir das erfasst werden da kann man halt dieses verführ wahlweb Hessen.
Du musst das quasi ich hoffe das ist das jetzt grob korrekt erklären.
Jedes Bundesland,
hat er dann unterschiedlich also in pc-wahl konntest du quasi sagen in welchem Bundesland du jetzt Daten übermittelt und die haben dann quasi unterschiedliche Wege gehabt wie diese Daten,
in diese
in irgendeiner Form der zentral hinkommen und die haben jetzt also zu zu den alten Zeiten war das quasi so dieser FTP-Server auf den alle lesen alle schreiben konnten wo du als einzelnes Wahllokal einfach die Ergebnisse von allen anderen auslesen manipulieren konntest
und jetzt haben sie sich da irgendwie umgestiegen und zwar,
anscheinend vollständig auf eine webmaske die da eingegeben wurde die vorher glaube ich auch schon,
benutzt werden konnte wo ich mir aber jetzt nicht so sicher bin und das hat den leider nicht hat leider nicht so wirklich funktioniert ne.
Das scheint Probleme gegeben zu haben wobei mir jetzt in den in den Medien Lage da noch etwas,
ein unvollständiges Bild bekommen habe wär jetzt eigentlich wo was eingegeben hat weil auf der einen Seite ist davon die Rede seht das ja mal mit tausend Usern getestet und bei 5000 Wahlbezirken sei es jetzt um die aus dem Tritt
kommen diese Software
deine Seite ist davon die Rede dass hier telefonisch Übermittlung gemacht haben und 40 PC-Arbeitsplätze bereitgestellt haben um dort wo Zusagen zu erfassen
also da wurde dann quasi von Telefon in die Software hinein transkribiert von diesen 40 Plätzen hätten aber nur 2 funktioniert.
Sodass wir noch um die auch schon davon ausgehen können dass die Software jetzt schon beim 40 Usern irgendwie
die Grätsche gemacht hat vollkommen unklar ist also auf jeden Fall ein Problem und man sei auch noch am prüfen ja also die Spezialisten unserer IT Abteilung arbeiten fieberhaft daran die Ursache der Probleme zu finden,
wird's hier der Landeswahlleiter zitiert wie mich halt fragen muss irgendwie dürfen eigentlich die Spezialisten,
im Fieberwahn überhaupt arbeiten oder müssen die sich nicht frei nehmen vielleicht können Sie ja auch einfach mal entspannt machen und.
Offensichtlich wissen sie noch nicht so richtig was zu insta bilität beigetragen hat ja und dieser Test mit tausend Usern ich meine Test kann man heutzutage gerade im Web,
hervorragend automatisieren kann es kein Problem sein da mal den Parameter von 1000 auf 5000 hoch zu drehen wenn es denn nun wirklich so gewesen sein soll das da 5000 Wahlbezirke,
zum selben Zeitpunkt die Ergebnisse übermitteln was ich für ausgesprochen unwahrscheinlich halte,
kann noch ein paar andere Sachen dazu Klassiker sowie da wurden halt mal die Ergebnisse falsch fabuliert das mal irgendwo
verschiedene Häufchen gebildet wurde je nachdem wie irgendwas angekreuzt wurde beim Auszählen und dann wurden dann diese häufigen kumuliert und das kumulierte Ergebnis,
wurde nicht übermittelt sein eben nur das von einem Häuschen gut das ist alles so Sachen und der Wahlleiter meinte ja auch wäre auch alles total kein Problem weil liegt ja alles auf Papier vor kann ja nachgezählt werden.
Ja geil, das doch ging das doch super.
Ja wie schön ist dass dass das so ist und nicht naja unsere IT Spezialisten sind noch dabei herauszufinden was mit den Wal Computern.
Sie arbeiten fieberhafter das ist es auch das ist auch hier ne Thema Krisenmanagement ne wenn du in einer Krise bist und irgendwo jemand fieberhaft arbeitet,
sorg dafür dass die nicht mehr fieberhaft arbeiten müssen und zweitens hier wird der Thorsten rössinger aufsagen,
du sagst nicht dass die fieberhaft arbeiten du sagst dass sie sehr geordnet und strategisch vorgehen und sie das Problem sehr genau angucken aber die arbeiten fieberhaft.
Ja
Verein zu sagen um zu erkennen wo überhaupt das Problem woran das Problem überhaupt liegt so ist halt echt.
Ja nach zwei Wochen könnte man ja mal die Ursache vielleicht auch schon mal so halbwegs eingekreist haben naja also.
Wir arbeiten fieberhaft daran die Ursache zu finden ist wirklich so noch das ist die aller erste Stufe der Krise.
Aber man sieht halt schön jetzt da dran auch wenn dir die Gründe andere sind.
Mann will sowas nicht hören ja also man will nicht hören dass bei einer Wahl ist irgendwie unklar ist und lustige ist ja auch,
dieses immer dieses Argument mit am Ende zählt ja nicht jede Stimme,
gerade die Seitenwahl zählt diesmal echt jede Stimme ich weiß nicht was der letzte Stand ist aber zwischenzeitlich war wohl der Stimmen Unterschied zwischen grüne und SPD in Hessen so im zweistelligen Bereich.
Mit anderen Worten.
Prozente oder prozent.
Und dementsprechend kommt sie Recht auf jede Stimme an Warum naja klar die Anteile und so das bleibt natürlich alles gleich aber hier wäre jetzt im Falle einer Koalition Verhandlungen unter Beteiligung der Grünen und der SPD.
Also wenn sie überzeugen mit einem dritten Partner wie z.b. den linken sich da doch durchringen würden,
eine Koalition zu bilden würde darüber halten entscheiden wer hier eigentlich das Ministerpräsidenten Amt übernehmen würde.
Also Wahlen müssen schon sehr genau sein und es ist die gute Nachricht ist hier.
Alles ist auf Papier alles kann nachgezählt werden nimmt euch Zeit ja uns egal arbeitet bitte nicht fieberhaft ihr könnt auch gerne noch zwei Wochen weitererzählen,
weil ist egal ja wichtig ist was hinten rauskommt wie hat Größe schön sagt oder wurde Simone unterstellt ich weiß es nicht und,
das mit den Computer an das übernommen.
Es zeigt aber auch dass durch das Entfernen von pc-wahl jetzt nicht auf einmal die Welt eine bessere ist es ist einfach nur ein anderes System was jetzt,
ebenfalls Schrott ist und der einzige Weg für Sonnensystem aufzufallen,
ist dass es nicht funktioniert hätte das jetzt in irgendeiner Formfehler funktioniert oder hätte es Schwachstellen gehabt dann wäre das nicht aufgefallen das heißt nur der Ausfall ist das dass sie überhaupt mal selber darauf aufmerksam werden und,
Beispiel refreshing memories sage also bisher konnten wir das mit pc-wahl machen und da hat alles super geklappt aber jetzt sind diese Chaos Computer,
Girl Chaoten gekommen und haben uns den Spaß weggenommen ja und jetzt sitzen wir mit 2 PCs und suchen fieberhaft nach der Ursache
das seid ihr da ist noch lange nicht aufgeräumt da ist auch bei allen anderen Lösung noch gut Futter.
Disida verwenden und es ist auch leider nur ein
trauriges Beispiel dafür dass Wahlen und alti grundsätzlich in einem ganz fürchterlichen Zustand ist und wer weiß wer sich da als nächstes noch irgendwas anschaut und was,
dann da noch gefunden werden könnte.
Das wird jetzt,
also ich freue mich wie gesagt darüber dass wir überhaupt die Möglichkeit haben hier eine Auszählung nachträglich durchzuführen da bin ich mal ganz gespannt wie das hier
so in USA abläuft da wird ja mindestens in Florida noch mal neu gezählt und das würde ich ja gerne mal sehen wie so ein Wahlcomputer neu durchgezählt.
Da werden wir bestimmt irgendwas im Display haben so erzählt irgend so ein Counter und hat es gedauert.
Und Deckel aufmachen einfach mal die die Beinchen zählen auch von den Chips oder so was nicht.
Wir sehen auf jeden Fall in Hessen nicht das erste Mal hat uns Papier den Arsch gerettet.
So siehts aus.
So wir bleiben eigentlich bei Referenzen zu vorangegangenen Sendungen Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Was kommt denn jetzt.
Da bekam ich irgendwann auch letzte Woche war das dann kurz vor der Veröffentlichung dieser Story anrufe
Meiderich verbrannt heißen Story dran und zwar Atomkraftwerke die Akkus Atomkraftwerks Pläne die gestohlen wurden und Atomendlager Städten Pläne und gefängnisplanet können Sie als Experte da was zu sagen und habe ich gesagt ja,
also erstens wunderlich mich das ist doch gar nicht neu und zweitens ich bin kein Experte für Atomkraftwerke Atomendlager Städten und Gefängnis.
Was war geschehen.
Wir haben damals in LocoNet fertig in unserer Sendung nicht darüber gesprochen weil das offenbar wie ich jetzt feststelle eine nichtöffentliche Information war aus welchen Gründen.
Unten in Dortmund im wissenschaftsladen die Türen eingetreten und der Server rausgetragen worden,
ich dachte eigentlich wir hätten darüber noch berichtet haben wir aber in der Sendung selber nicht weil die war der Fall damals noch zu Neuwahlen.
Denn auf dem Server der dort entfernt wurde ja wo die Polizei so ruppig vorgegangen ist das ganze Haus durchsucht hat den Chaos Treff Dortmund noch mit mit durchsucht hat und so weiter.
Wir haben ja auch mit dem Kollektiv damals noch eine Live-Schaltung gehabt die diesen Server betreiben und wissen das war ja quasi ein.
Kollektiv betriebenes ein Kollektiv betriebener Server wo man sich ebenso ein bisschen face drauf holen konnte.
Ja da ihm gesagt wurde okay wir kümmern uns darum und dieses kollektivleben auch diese.
Dangelmaier ohne großartige Formalia da die Möglichkeit bereitgestellt hat einen Account zu errichten.
Stellt sich raus auf diesem Server hatte wohl irgendjemand unklar wer,
Informationen aus einem Heck des Unternehmens on Europe,
ich habe eine Mischung aus Ingenieur und Europa oder sowas g.
Hochgeladen die da irgendwie oft vermutlich so die Theorie nicht unbedingt unter legalen Umständen rausgekommen sind.
Insbesondere eben gerade sagte Bauplan ein Planet zum Bau eines Hochsicherheitsgefängnis Unterlagen zu einem geplanten Atommüll-Endlager persönliche Informationen zu mehr als 1.200 Mitarbeitenden,
dieses Unternehmens und auch firmeninterne E-Mails,
Soda für die Vorgehensweise der Polizei ist bekannt die am Türen eingetreten Haus durchsucht den Server daraus gerissen kurze Zeit später.
Sind die Daten wieder im Netz nur dieses Mal mehr und zwar ganze 65gb in einem,
in der Berichterstattung ist vom Darknet die Rede ich gehe davon aus dass sie damit ein Tor hidden Service mein also jetzt einen Server auf dem man nicht so schnell findet und der,
hier in dem Fall sogar noch mehr,
Daten veröffentlicht als die ursprünglich dort auf dem Angebot des Kollektivs kostet haben tja.
Ich kann ja leider nicht viel mehr zu sagen weil ich nicht weiß was also die Baupläne eines Hochsicherheitsgefängnisse sind sicherlich interessant Unterlagen von geplant natür Müll Endlager weiß ich nicht.
Interessantes oder.
Ja oder also ist er mir da natürlich der französische Inlandsgeheimdienst und mit Sicherheit sind das hier kritische Informationen inwiefern die Veröffentlichung dieser Informationen.
Eine Gefahr ist ist kann ich leider nicht beurteilen weil ich sie nicht verstehe also soll nicht heißen sie will das nicht runterspielen oder sonst was könnte sein ich weiß nicht wie man Atomkraftwerke baut,
ich war noch nie im Hochsicherheitsgefängnis insofern kann ich tatsächlich nicht beurteilen wie kritisch,
diese Informationen sind aber ich kann auf jeden Fall beurteilen dass es wahrscheinlich besser ist wenn man die,
Information bei Unternehmen vor hält die sich nicht irgendwie von oben bis unten auf Haken lassen.
Bei das auch zugegebenermaßen,
sehr schwierig ist ja wir reden ja hier von offenbar 1200 mit arbeitenden diese das sind ja auch Großprojekte na wenn du wenn Du ernsthaft beabsichtigst ein Hochsicherheitsgefängnis zu bauen,
dann ist es schwierig den Bauplan dafür geheimzuhalten weil du kannst ja nicht alleine bauen,
das ist du musst irgendjemand muss ja die.
Muss ja auch die Drecksarbeit machen das Ding aus dem Boden zu stampfen und dafür musst du Menschen Zugang zu teilen,
des Bauplanes geben und ein Mensch alleine kann sowas nicht planen sondern so was geschieht in den riesigen Teams die daneben auch zusammenarbeiten müssen und dann hast du auf einmal eine große Gruppe Personen die Zugriff auf eine bestimmte Information,
haben müssen weil sonst ihre Arbeit nicht verrichten können und gleichzeitig hast du jetzt auf einmal geheimhaltungs Ansprüche,
gegenüber dieser Informationen dummer was am Ende passiert David hat irgendeiner gehackt von deinen von deinen Leuten und dann arbeiten sich die Angreifer.
In Ruhe vorwärts.
Weil meine wenn man jetzt sagt so ihr habt aber Daten nicht ordentlich gesichert also bei Bauplänen wird es natürlich jetzt in Zukunft ohnehin nervlich weil
eigentlich alle größeren Projekte heutzutage schon komplett digital durchgeführt werden dann werden die entsprechenden Architektur.
Formation management.
Genau da diese pim-systeme das ist einfach erforderlich daneben für kollektives planen und überprüfen Netcetera Sicherheitsanlagen,
ganze bestellen das Material ist alles läuft da drüber macht ja auch durchaus Sinn so etwas zu optimieren digital zu digitalisieren aber schafft natürlich damit auch wieder komplett neue angriffsvektoren,
einfach weil die Daten dann ohnehin irgendwie im Zugriff sind damit hast du natürlich noch nicht automatisch Zugriff auf suche die Rohdaten und vollständig der mich jetzt mit pimp selbst zu wenig aus als dass ich das jetzt konkreter formulieren könnte nur,
so etwas haben bis jetzt hier zu tun na gut du mal weiter.
Genau also ich würde trotzdem sagen das sind teilw größtenteils durch project die noch nicht gebaut wurden insofern denke ich das Fazit ist,
du musst heute jetzt eben anders bauen da müsste jetzt ihre Pläne ändern sicherheitskritische Dinge haben.
Anders gestalten und den Schaden dafür trägt natürlich das Unternehmen das ja hier relativ offensichtlich auch Ziel dieses Angriffs war,
ansonsten weiß ich nicht ob sich das Prinzip an dann den Bau von Gebäuden übertragen lässt das obscurity eben keine Security ist.
Und man daraus schließen könnte dein Bauplan darf eben auch keiner Geheimhaltung bedürfen.
Wenn man du ein ernsthaft wenn wenn sich jetzt für Menschen aus dem Blick auf den Bauplan Sicherheitslücken ergeben würden,
das weiß ich nicht ob dieses Prinzip anwendbar ist dafür habe ich zu wenig Ahnung von Architektur.
Ja schwierig ich meine allein schon so Sachen wie Fluchttunnel und so weiter das kann alles irgendwie ein Sicherheitsproblem sein nicht unbedingt jetzt für eine Intrusionen aber halt auch für
die Sicherheit der Leute im Fall von irgendeinem Angriff gerade gezogen Fängen des Befreiungsaktion keine Ahnung was weiß ich.
Der Stimmbänder Männergefängnis Befreiungsaktion brauchst den ordentlichen Tunnel das ist richtig.
Ja das ist sonst einfacher viel zu gefährlich.
Mituso Feuer,
terzetto nur du kein Witz ist,
das Interesse an die zentralen identifikations Diensten nimmt ein wenig Fahrt auf jetzt auch in Deutschland wovon reden wir alle suchen händeringend nach,
Alternativen zu dieser Realität dass viele Dienste im Web.
Nicht unbedingt immer über eigene Login Systeme verfügen wollen,
z&w auch andere Gründe haben hier einfach sich bei den großen zu bedienen Login via Facebook Login via Twitter.
Ähnliche Login Systeme bei anderen großen Plattform Gitter pcetera Facebook und Twitter sind hier sicherlich weit vorne Facebook sicherlich ganz weit vorne mit anderen Worten.
Da kommt ein neuer Dienst da ja ich möchte den benutzen habe jetzt keinen Bock auf diesen hesselauf Passwort wieder eingeben welches nehme ich denn da kein Passwort Manager installiert entweder man nimmt immer dasselbe Passwort oder,
wann macht es dann halt einfach nicht 80 hier via facebook ist ja total super mache ich halt das Problem dabei ist.
In dem Moment wird natürlich auch dieser Vorgang bei Facebook,
registriert wieder ein weiterer Datenpunkt wieder eine weitere Verknüpfung wieder ein neues Interesse was automatisch in einer Datensammlung landet und überhaupt,
da eine Datenschutz und Privatsphäre Pest
TV drauf wo man das vielleicht nicht machen möchte aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Gründe hier vielleicht auf andere Systeme setzen zu wollen und die Faulheit der Leute an der Stelle
zu nutzen indem man einfach sagt na ja was Facebook kann können wir schon lange werden ja auch ein Interesse solche Daten zu sammeln also Baum uns doch und dann eigenen.
Ich würde das noch mal ein bisschen auf eine ganz andere Metaebene noch mal holen das Internet ist.
Susi ist eine sehr lange Zeit,
der Ort gewesen an dem du nicht gezwungen warst eine einzige Identität zu haben.
Du konntest Dich bei Twitter als Hasen Häschen 23 anmelden und bei Facebook,
durftest es zwar nicht aber Gottes sich da auch unter anderem Namen anmelden und wenn du dich ins IRC eingewählt hast konntest du jeden Tag einen anderen,
Nickname nehmen wenn du das für notwendig gehalten hast und nicht deinen vielleicht irgendwann einmal registrierten zu nutzen das heißt diese,
diese Online-Welt war sehr lange eine in der du in allen möglichen Kontexten immer wieder neue Identitäten.
Finden oder erfinden konntest und das ist ein mich gut.
Kannst du auch mal noch mal.
Ja aber es ist relativ klar dass die Motivation dahin geht dass das ein Ende findet die Rennen nämlich die ganze Zeit Leute die Tür ein und sagen personalausweispflicht im Internet,
Klassiker.
Ich will wissen wer das ist wenn du dich hier äußerst dann musst du es wenigstens unter deinem eigenen Namen tun du hast Facebook die als eine sehr,
sehr sehr,
ekelige Strategie gesagt haben na ja pass auf unser Login Verfahren wird wir benutzen das quasi als.
Möglichkeit dein eigenen Login zu vereinfachen ne du bist bei Facebook eingeloggt dann kannst du jetzt mit einem Klick Teil dieses nächsten Dienstes werden,
Ja und Facebook bleibt deine Login Maske das machen die unter die die anderen Unternehmen ja nicht unbedingt weil sie das geil finden sondern weil sie damit den die,
die Anzahl ihrer Nutzerinnen und Nutzer erhoffen in die Höhe zu treiben,
indem sie das Anmelden einfacher machen ne das ist eigentlich der der der Wunsch den den du jetzt vielleicht auch als,
Unternehmen hast du das eigentlich in irgendeiner Form in Konkurrenz mit facebook steht und sei es nur,
das Facebook deine Idee so gut sind dass wir einfach kopieren wie sonst auch und da wird dein dein Geschäftsmodell mehr oder weniger erledigen.
Sondern du hast eben auch eine Treppe zusammen ok derzeit ab Prozess muss bei uns so einfach wie möglich sein und wenn jemand sich über Facebook einloggt dann können wir brauchen wir im keine
Bestätigungs-E-Mail mehr zusenden wir müssen nicht mehr zwingen sich ein eigenes Passwort einfallen zu lassen sondern die Person ist eingeloggt als Facebook und wenn sie in Facebook eingeloggt ist kommt sie auf unserer Seite und ist automatisch auch eingeloggt.
Und du erbst natürlich dann die ganze Arbeit und Sicherheitstechnik die halt bei so einem zentralen Login Dienst quasi automatisch geleistet werden muss muss das nicht alles auch noch selber stecken.
Und du lieferst schön deine deine Accounts woanders direkt auch noch mit anan Facebook sehr.
Das hat so seine vor und seine Nachteile nicht kann so ein Dienst mal eben schnell hochziehen so und,
oft macht davon auch dann sind wir nur eben die die Aktivitäten in den jeweiligen Plattform machst so war es ja am Anfang haben wir ja auch schon in 1000 Kontexten du wahr berichtet.
Ich mag aber eben auch den anderen Vektor geben dass man sagt na ja warum musst du immer alles so kompliziert sein und es hätte ja auch ein
Vorteil wenn du einen zentralen identifikations Dienst benutzt weil du dann eben auch die zu die erlaubten Zugriffe auch zentral mal steuern kannst da,
wenn das so ausgeführt ist also ich würde es nicht generell,
dämonisieren wollen das hat verschiedene Aspekte so oder so geht jetzt gerade ein.
Trotzdem sorry noch mal da eingrenzen denn okay.
Wir können das ja gleich auch noch mal debattieren überfällt sollen wir das mal erzählen was überhaupt die Realität ist oder ich wollte ja überhaupt erst mal erklären es gibt diese Dienste bisher war es halt Facebook und Twitter jetzt gibt's in Deutschland.
Eine weitere gab auch schon vorher eine andere und vielleicht gibt aber ein paar live jetzt übersehen haben eine neue Initiative die heißt nett,
Aldi und
macht im Prinzip genau das ne Login Auftrittszeiten anbieten mit einem existierenden Account so unternehmen halt so verschiedene üblich würde ich die GE jetzt dran Teil auf der einen Seite also der Seite sieht quasi deine Identität schon
kennt und anderen zum Login bereitstellt und so WEB.DE GMX einfacher 1 bekannte Vertreter,
und sie wird gesagt es seien halt damit potentiell 35000000 aktive Accounts
theoretisch net-id fähig dazu brauchst du um das natürlich zu benutzen auch noch mal Webseiten die selber dann wiederum auch einen sprechenden Login mit nett Aldi anbieten,
da gibt's derzeit 60 Webseiten das Angebot ist sicherlich an der Stelle noch ausbaubar.
Yalman will hier
dann eben entsprechend Transparenz schaffen nur das heißt du loggst dich irgendwo ein und wenn du dann das tust dann kriegst du dann eben auch gleich die Information welche Informationen hier denn dann auch geteilt wurden ja also wurde E-Mail-Adresse von Lieferadressen Geburtsdatum RC abgefragt und geliefert,
und im Idealfall hast du dann bei deinem identitäts Anbieter der quasi über diesen,
einheitlichen net-id Vorgang deine Identität Dritten zur Verfügung stellt wenn du das denn möchtest hast du dann eben auch ein entsprechendes user interface
um diese Daten zu verwalten da das aber jetzt sozusagen von unterschiedlichen Anbietern bereitgestellt wird hast du auch bei jedem Anbieter eine andere,
User Experience ja also bei Anbieter AMAG das alles so einzustellen sein aber es muss ja dort implementiert werden innerhalb dieses Systems deswegen hast du auch kein,
einheitliches User-Interface und dann hängt mal ganz davon ab was denn so das Interesse
des jeweiligen Anbieters ist hier dran teilzunehmen daran teilzunehmen heißt ja auch einerseits die eigene Account Basis dritten,
schmackhaft zu machen so nach dem Motto hier hast du einen coolservice und den kannst du sogar benutzen um dein ganzes Netz zu betreten.
Andererseits weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau wie da jetzt die Deals innerhalb dieser Initiative sind.
Markus der unterschiedliche Präferenzen geben was sind jetzt hier irgendwie wichtig ist ja da im Wesentlichen mitzuspielen oder dir die bestmöglichen Datenschutz und Transparenz über die Vorgänge zu bieten das muss man,
sehen also user interfaces lassen hier wohl teilweise noch zu wünschen übrig ist bisschen schwierig ist die richtige Einstellung zu finden um Verbindungen wieder zu lösen das kann ich jetzt selber nicht beurteilen,
es gibt ein zweites Projekt heißt verimi die sind wohl schon im April gestartet,
die haben auch hier und da schon ein paar Mitstreiter gefunden was heißt das ist ein.
Ein nicht so ein offener Dienst der von mehreren implementiert werden kann sein so quasi ein Dienst den du aufsetzt und dann hast du eben entsprechende,
Teilnehmer die daneben den Login mit diesem Account ermöglichen,
Deutsche Telekom seida dabei Deutsche Bahn Bundesdruckerei Lufthansa axel-springer ich habe ehrlich gesagt und login button,
bei diesen Unternehmen in dem Moment wo ich mich dort irgendwie eingeloggt habe noch nirgendwo gesehen das mag also auch nur für sehr ausgewählt Dienste gelten,
hast du schon mal gesehen und wo.
Größtenteils nutze ich nicht die Dienste wo es das gibt aber ich halte ich habe ja auch ein fundamentales Problem überhaupt mit der Idee.
Du hast kein Account bei der Bundesdruckerei.
War ich über andere.
Ja weiß ich so fliegen oder Telekom oder sowas da ist man ja auch schon mal Kunde ich auch nicht genau.
Aber ich möchte meine Fundamentalkritik jetzt äußern was das letzte was wir brauchen.
Und was hier jemand brauchte war eine zentrale Identität im Internet.
Niemand will eine Identität haben Identität ist etwas was am Ende gegen dich steht und gegen dich arbeitet,
was du haben möchtest gegenüber Facebook,
gegenüber einem E-Mail-Anbieter gegenüber irgendeinem Forum wo du dich anmeldest gegen wo man wo man sich irgendwie so reingelegt ja irgend so eine Apple ID dann wieder eine lag,
Marke mit mit Facebook Integration und klick hier und sowas hat wir wollen im Internet keine,
zentrale Identität haben das ist das eine Ding was das Internet nicht brauchte,
was bei wir jahrelang ohne klargekommen sind und jetzt wird's Zeit.
Einigen Jahren ist das eben das neue wissensmodell was Leute sehen dass sie glauben dass identitäts Provider,
ja quasi der der Schritt wäre dauert eine dauerhafte monopolartige Stellung im Internet,
zu erlangen ohne die nichts mehr geht indem du nämlich der oder die Identität Provider bist und.
Genauso hast du.
Du da da passiert ein entscheidender Denkfehler wenn du mich von dem von dem Komfort gesprochen wird.
Beispiel in Unternehmen hast du sowas wie,
eine Smartcard ja diese Smartcard wird genutzt für dein deine zugangsverwaltung im Gebäude,
und du wirst dann bestimmten Gruppen zugeordnet und das heißt du kannst vorne durch die Tür rein du kannst aber nicht in den Hochsicherheitsbereich aber du kannst in dem Bereich und das wird zentral geschaltet ja jetzt hast du also eine Karte die deine Berechtigungen.
Speichert dich in diesem Gebäude zu bewegen und jetzt gehen einige Unternehmen hin und sagen ey, wenn wir doch schon diese Smartcard haben dann können wir ja auch noch auf kontaktloses Zahlen in der,
Cafeteria umsteigen dann hast du jetzt auf deiner Smartcard außerdem noch ein Guthaben mit dem du in der Cafeteria bezahlen kannst alles super und wenn die jetzt beispielsweise keine Ahnung hast du jetzt noch an.
Parkplatz im.
Im in der Tiefgarage dann könnte man das auch noch darauf speichern ja und von mir aus könnte man noch eine ganze Reihe anderes damit machen z.b. könnte das eine Karte werden mit der du bezahlen kannst z.b. in anderen Ländern hat wo du mit deiner mit deiner Prepaid U-Bahn Karte,
im seven eleven bezahlen kannst ja wo die,
Didi die kontaktlose U-Bahn Fahrkarte auch ein Zahlungsmittel in Spezies ist,
alles super schöne Sachen und alle diese Sachen funktionieren ohne Identität denn was die Karte da realisiert für dich ist,
eine Berechtigung oder eine capability und genau nicht eine Identität und deswegen glaube ich ist es nicht gut.
Überhaupt ein Verfahren sich anzuvertrauen was im Namen schon hat wir sind jetzt deine Identität wir sind ein Unternehmen das deine Identität gegenüber anderen Unternehmen verwaltet.
Und das ist einfach nicht das was wir haben wollen niemand will im Internet eine Identität haben wir wollen Berechtigungen haben Berechtigung sich als dieser oder jener Account irgendwo einzuloggen na das ist alles in Ordnung aber in identitäts Provider
willst du nicht haben denn der arbeitet am Ende gegen dich.
Also ich weiß nicht ob ich das so pauschal sagen kann dass ich irgendwie nicht auch,
meine ich muss ja auch manchmal meine Identität und damit auch meine Berechtigung die ja damit verknüpft ist,
zum Besten geben und in irgendeiner Form muss dieser Vorgang ja durchgeführt werden
so und jetzt hat muss er halt dann auch für dich von jedem einzelnen Unternehmen auch immer wieder komplett repliziert und entsprechend abgesichert werden mit den ganzen
Rattenschwänzchen dia dranhängen mit Speicherung der Daten und richtige Prozesse und muss irgendwie alles ordentlich abgeliefert werden,
Carsharing ja also was weiß ich jeder Roller Dienst jeder Autoverleih Dienst wo ich mich anmelde
muss ich immer wieder durch diese Prozedur sie mich da mit irgend so einem Webworker mit seiner webcam unterhalten halbe Stunde meinen Führerschein in die Kamera Wedel,
um sozusagen zu beweisen dass ich auch ich bin und Kraft meines ich dann auch berechtigt bin ein bestimmtes Fahrzeug zu mieten z.
Ja das ist genau das ist erstens also in einem solchen Fall ist das,
gut dass du dann einen Prozess hast indem du eben deine deinen identitäts Ding und deine Berechtigung,
Pforzheim kannst denn dem Autoverleiher ist der braucht halt deine Identität für die Rechnungsadresse und deine deinen einen Nachweis über deine Berechtigung zum Führen eines Autos
das ist okay weil der mit dir einen Vertrag eingehen muss
aber das an einer zentralen Stelle zu verweilen und im Prinzip dafür zu zu einer Situation zu führen dass du deine dass du die hoheitliche Aufgabe des Staates nämlich das Bestätigen deiner Identität.
Mittels Personalausweis.
Oder der die die Bestätigung deiner Berechtigung zum Führen eines Fahrzeuges mittels,
Führerschein willst du ja nicht in in den Händen eines solchen Unternehmens haben,
haben Beispiel Führerschein und Personalausweis sind in die wunderschöne wunderschönes Beispiel wenn du angehalten wirst von der Polizei und die sagen sie möchten gerne deinen Führerschein sehen dann steht da nicht deine Adresse drauf,
bei der Führerschein einfach nur sagt diese Person darf eine Auto fahren.
Und deswegen steht da nicht drauf Augenfarbe grün 1970 große wohnt hier in hast du nicht gesehen,
weil das weil diese Informationen nicht notwendig sind und genau deshalb würde ich nicht alle diese Informationen zentral bei egal wem speichern lassen lassen
Errungenschaft dass das nicht so ist und in diesem Fall hättest du ja sogar dann an bei diesem Unternehmen nicht nur stehen was weiß ich ist folgende Person sondern würde Aufstehen hat einen Twitter Account und zwar welchen oder hat einen Facebook Account und zwar welchen und ruckzuck,
Kutschen alle Unternehmen auf dieses so komfortable Verfahren um wie es nämlich jetzt auch bei Facebook der Fall ist und du wirst am Ende an einer zentralen Stelle mehr oder weniger deine komplette
eine Identität zusammen und wenn du dann das machst und zweiten Twitter Account dann bindest du den unter Umständen auch noch in deiner Identität und das,
halte ich nicht für den richtigen Ansatz und nicht für das was wir benötigen.
Ja gut aber ich meine wenn ich so eine Business identitäts mir aufbaue und es wirklich einfach nur darum geht das aber korrekt zu kommunizieren wo ich auch teilweise dazu verpflichtet bin
diese Transparenz an den Tag zu legen und wurde sich dabei auch nicht im eigentlichen Sinne um private Informationen Handelswaren Dinge die ich sowieso auf jeder Impressums Webseite drauf schreiben muss et cetera hallo XY ich bin Geschäftsführer von und Aufsichtsrat
bei ja was quasi auf jeden sing Profil.
Hättest du ganze Zeit trotzdem nicht die ganze Zeit mit deinem XING-Profil durch die Gegend.
Muss auch nicht aber in dem Moment wo man sozusagen sich Dritten gegenüber nachweisen will,
ist es ja durchaus eine praktische Geschichte das will ich diese Information ohnehin schon beisammen habe dass diese dann eben auch nachprüfbar für einen konkreten autorisierungs Vorgang genutzt.
Warst du eben mit einem Personalausweis ja schon hast
wenn wir den wenn wir diesen online Personalausweis halbwegs vernünftig bestellt hätten hättest du die wenigen Male deines Lebens wo du mal jemand einen Personalausweis zeigen musst um deine Identität nachzuweisen abarbeiten können.
Euer schönes noch mal weiter gehen wir mal weg von diesen Firmen die jetzt hier versuchen diesen Platz zu besetzen so ne,
und was auch immer ihre Motivation im Einzelnen jetzt primär sein mag und darum gibt auch das zu machen was facebook macht oder tat sich ging dagegen über eine Verbesserung der
Transparenz oder Privatsphäre zu erreichen was müsste denn der Staat machen.
Also ich meine irgendeiner der Staat ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht schon meine identity Provider weil man glaubt ja dann meinen Personalausweis man glaubt man Führerschein.
Weil da habe ich einen Ausweis von der glitzert schön wenn man in die Kamera hält und hat Wasserzeichen
und ist schön offiziell und jetzt will ich das ganz gerne für online da bin ich mir nicht für jeden einzelnen Dienst immer wieder komplett mit irgendwelchen Fremden über ihre s***** unterhalten.
Princess mal gemacht was will das nicht oft machen.
Willst du willst es vor allem mit nicht machen müssen du wirst bei dem wenigsten musst du das tun.
Bleibe ruhig mal bei diesem Carsharing Beispiel was ist das halt ab die wollen deinen Führerschein sehen.
Ja und da muss
so musste fünf Minuten kurz mal mit denen reden was im Übrigen ein Verfahren ist gegen das eh irgendwie Beschwerden und Sicherheitsmängel anhängig sind und wenn wir Glück haben wird dieser Stoß halt auch wieder gestrichen.
Warum ist das so ein Stuss jetzt also.
Alles ist in der Aufgabe für ein Teenager ist mal eben mit so einem Greenscreen dafür zu sorgen dass auf einem auf einer wackelnden Karte mal ein paar kurze Reflektion eines Hologramms auftauchen,
halten wachsen also was die anmachen ist du hältst ja dann deine deinen Führerschein oder deinen Personalausweis dahin und dann sagen die bewegen Sie ein bitte einmal hin und her damit ich den Glitzer sehe,
zuerst natürlich völlig lächerliche Prüfung sodass wartet ja nur mal jemand drauf.
Aber was würdest du vorschlagen wie ich online mich gegenüber Dritten nicht online gegenüber Dritten Nachweise dass ich die Berechtigungen habe ein Auto zu führen.
Durch einen derzeit angemessenen digitalen Nachweis im Zweifelsfall über eine kontaktlose Smart Karte.
Die ist dann über meinen Teppich rosa Streiche.
Wo du dann einfach mal Apple soweit bringst dass sie dir den NFC freischalten und ab geht die Katze wäre problemlos seit seit Jahren möglich mit der Hardware die alle in der Tasche tragen.
Also etwas über Lilith.
PIN PIN geschützt ja Cavalese dead PIN geschützt natürlich damit
die nicht weil die ganzen Strategen ihr Smartphone und die ganzen NFC Karten in der gleichen Tasche transportieren damit da kein auslesen ohne deinen Interesse stattfinden kann völlig okay.
Dafür eine sinnvolle Lösung.
Und das reicht dann deiner Meinung nach.
Besser als dass ich irgendwie mein Leben lang im Internet rum renne mit einem Cookie von irgendeinem Unternehmen namens net-id oder verimi die dann ein Geschäftsmodell daraus entwickelt haben meine Identität zu verwalten.
Gut lassen wir das ja an der Stelle einfach mal als freies Kommentar Futter stehen also,
habe es auch nur ehrlich gesagt noch keine richtig klare Position dazu ich sehe dass ich ihr das Netz.
Schwierig ist für die Leute so ja und diese Dienste Abhilfe schaffen und damit im Prinzip komplett neues.
Ich glaube dass dass ich bin mir nicht sicher dass das eine gute Idee ist.
Also ich bin einfach der Idee der Identität im Netz gegenüber äußerst skeptisch was ich verwalten möchte sind Berechtigungen und Befähigung.
So Berechtigung und Befähigung werden auch in Schweden verwaltet vom Gericht nämlich z.b. die Berechtigung zu grillen,
zu einer Webseite zu liefern und wir kennen das ab und zu gibt es Beschwerden und,
irgendwelche Pulsationen möchten nicht dass man auf bestimmte Webseiten zugreift ganz oben auf der Liste der des Verfolgungswahn ist hier die schöne Webseite seischab.
Die der wissenschaftlichen Community weltweit ein interessantes Angebot macht nämlich die nicht weniger als den Zugang zu allen wissenschaftlichen papers die Verbreitung gefunden haben.
Weiß noch nicht so die Verbreitung gefunden haben dass man mühelos auf sie online zugreifen konnte und,
da wie durch ein Wunder finden alle paper hier Zugang zu diesem Archiv.
Das finden ein paar Unternehmen nicht so gut nämlich vor allem die die in den ganze Menge Geld damit verdienen den Zugang zu wissenschaftlichen PayPal gewinnbringend zu,
verkaufen ganz vorne ist hier natürlich das Unternehmen Elsevier und also wir hatten in Schweden Jungs durchgesetzt
dass der Zugang zu sei hab der doch zu blocken seit oder hat sich damit vor allem vor Gericht durchgesetzt.
Gegenüber dem schwedischen Internet-Service-Provider Bahnhof,
der hat hat sich das deutsche Wort Bahnhof wird hier verwendet,
und Bahnhof hat das überhaupt nicht lustig hatte eben lange versucht sich dagegen zu wehren ist aber nun dazu gezwungen worden das zu machen aber.
Die haben nicht nur Bahnhof verstanden die wussten auch genau was zu tun ist und Bahnhof hat dann wiederum gleich noch eine zweite blockier Regelung zugefügt nämlich den Zugriff auf die Webseite von Elsevier.
Finde das unterhaltsam.
Witzig unterhaltsam nett fern sind immer scheiße und dann kann man es denen die sie veranlassen durchaus auch mal auf die harte Tour beispielhaft näher bringen.
Sehr bewusst nicht nur else wir gesperrt sollen sie haben auch es ist mir gerade der Umfang nicht ganz klar aber auch dieses Patentamt durch dass sie dadurch gegangen sind.
Und dieser rechts kleben durchgesetzt wurden jeglicher Traffic der von deren IP-Adresse kommt den haben sie irgendwie auch noch geblockt.
So nach dem Motto ja okay wir sollen blocken dann blocken wir,
na da werde ich ja sehen was er davon hab ich mal gespannt wie der Spaß ausgeht aufjedenfall Humor haben sie.
Der Bonbon Blogpost dazu hat einen anderen till aber unter der Tat der Dateiname ist die balkanisieren balkanisieren,
Dakine eising der balkanizer sehr schön.
Dann noch die AFD,
lässt sich ihre Verfassungsfeindlichkeit bescheinigen da können wir mal wieder sehen was wie wie wie schön dass so ein wissenschaftliche Analysen sind und Studien die man in Auftrag gibt in diesem Fall.
War die Aufgabe die die AFD Parteispitze hat ja Angst durch den Verfassungsschutz beobachtet zu werden.
Und wenn das passiert Wählerinnen und Mitglieder vielleicht zu verlieren deswegen haben sie eine Arbeitsgruppe Verfassungsschutz eingerichtet und diese Arbeitsgruppe Verfassungsschutz hat dann ein Gutachten erstellen lassen,
und zwar von dem Rechtswissenschaftler Dietrich murswiek der irgendwie auch schon auf dem Extremismus Kongress der AFD auftrat also jemand der vielleicht dieser Partei nicht,
vollständig abgeneigt ist und Smith breit ist sie mit spitzen Fingern anzufassen dann gibt es noch einen Herrn,
Roland Hartwig der stellvertretender Vorsitzender Bundestagsfraktion ist und eben der Leiter dieser,
der Arbeitsgruppe ist und dieses Gutachten von dem Herrn Professor Dieter murswiek zusammengefasst hat und da kommt,
überraschenderweise bei heraus dass die AFD einige.
Einige Gewohnheiten hat und ihre Mitglieder die durchaus einer verfassungsfeindlichen Gesinnung oder Bestrebungen,
anheim wird Erde auf eine verfassungsfeindliche Gesinnung oder Bestrebungen hindeuten also der Professor mursewiek definiert dann erstmal so was heißt überhaupt Verfassung ne das muss man den ja vielleicht auch mal kurz schreiben so oder,
das noch mal kurz erklären warum seid ihr geht,
was sind die Werte der Verfassung und was wäre dann eben Verfassungsfeindlichkeit und dann war eben auch Teil der,
Teil der Aufgabenstellung wie was die AFD machen müsste um,
diesem Problem zu entgehen ja also was müssen wir anders machen damit der der Verfassungsschutz uns in Ruhe lässt und da gibt es dieses Gutachten Empfehlungen also was sie als Design lassen sollte pauschale Diffamierung von Flüchtlingen,
das Infragestellen der in der Religionsfreiheit.
Das Verwenden extremistischer Reizwörter wie Überfremdung wenn man nicht als verfassungsfeindlicher Extremist gelten möchte möge man am besten die Zusammenarbeit mit extremistischen Organisationen einstellen,
man soll keine likes für Rechtsextremisten in sozialen Netzwerken verteilen ja ich glaube das wird jetzt am Ende nicht reichen für eine schöne verteile finde finde beobachte dich die Verfassungsschutz aber
man sollte auch unter seinen eigenen Mitgliedern möglich keine Mitglieder extremistischer Organisationen haben was ein bisschen schwierig ist für die AFD weil die ja irgendwie.
Man man man nie macht sich aber auch schwer.
Und und wenn die eigene Leute diese Grenzen überschreiten müsste man sich eben auch von den distanzieren statt ihnen beizupflichten und dann wird übermittelt das quasi die traurige.
Erkenntnis aus dem afd-vorstand gewesen wäre na ja dann können wir uns auch gleich auflösen so zitiert die tagesschau hier die Reaktionen,
aus dem Vorstand.
Seid ihr AFD einmal.
Im in ehrliche Studie bekommen zu haben wir jetzt mal gespannt ob sie dir jetzt auch irgendwie als als Fake News.
Diskreditieren wollen.
Ja wenn die Extremisten wenn sich alles so läuft wie Sie sich das vorstellen dann werden sie halt schnell zickig und reden schnell wieder am Rad,
nicht dass sie das nicht sonst auch tun würden das sieht man jetzt auch gerade wieder schön,
in den USA wo Jan und gerade die Mütter élections abgehalten worden sind
werdenstein lebte die Midterms sind halt so die halbzeitwahlen da wird dann kein Präsident gewählt aber ein großer Teil,
des Kongresses in beiden Kammern also sowohl the house also der ist.
House of Representatives.
Genau der Repräsentantenhaus und der Senat also die Vertretung der Bundesländer der 50,
Staaten von USA und ja das ist so.
Sonaya gelaufen diesmal,
die Demokraten haben immerhin im Repräsentantenhaus wieder eine Mehrheit wie es aussieht auch eine ganz ordentliche Mehrheit dass es schon mal ganz gut um,
den durchgedrehten Republikanern ist ein bisschen Stoppschild zu zeigen im Senat ist es nicht so gut gelaufen und.
Jetzt fragt sich natürlich alle wie geht's weiter das haben dann auch die Journalisten gefragt den Präsidenten natürlich persönlich auf der Pressekonferenz,
neueste da irgendwie durchgedreht also das war ja schon mal wieder eine neue Rekord.
Da muss er noch kurz sagen ist dass das die initiale Reaktion ist natürlich.
Trump hat diese Wahl ja stilisiert zu auch eine Abstimmung über sich selber spezifisch ist es ja auch,
ist ganz klar eine Wahl,
auf Bundesebene der Senat und das Repräsentantenhaus vorm den Kongress und das ist eine der verfällt eine der Verfassungsschutz den USA wieder weh wie heißt die Nummer Verfassungsorgan,
und der Präsident muss ja mit beiden Kammern in verschiedenen Verfahren verschiedenartig zusammenarbeiten so dass sein Leben.
Schwieriger wird wenn eine oder zwei dieser kann man nicht auch die Mehrheit seiner Partei haben.
Deswegen klar was nun passieren wird durch eine Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus ist Donald Trump auf,
bin in vielen Verfahren nun stark eingeschränkt hat ja dann auch sofort irgendwie,
es ist so geil hat er dann einen einen einen Lob geschrieben und irgendwie erstmal versucht Nancy Pelosi der jetzt
der meteoriti liderin des Repräsentantenhauses irgendwie so erstmal lifetime achievement award verliehen was ihr für eine tolle Politikerin ist und dass,
dass er sich freut mit ihr zusammenzuarbeiten.
Aber nur wenn sie ihn in Ruhe lässt.
Genau denn die Welt also die under türlich die Demokraten an ganz klar gesagt na ja alle möglichen
baumkontroll Untersuchungen über wie ihr hier das Geld ausgeben wie eure Interessenskonflikte sind und so die kann alle das Repräsentantenhaus an rollen
dummerweise bräuchte man aber auch eine relativ große Mehrheit im Kong im Senat um daraus dann irgendwann auch mal,
ernsthaftes Amtsenthebungsverfahren wachsen zu lassen und Franz Reaktion ist okay erstmal bei Nancy Pelosi schleimen dann,
sein Justizminister rauswerfen war schlecht ist weil der Justizminister der Dienstherr quasi ist von dem
Robert Maler der ja jetzt dann irgendwann mal hoffentlich auf dem Knipp kommt und seinen Bericht vorlegen wird und dieser Bericht wird ja dann eben auch im US-Repräsentantenhaus,
angeschaut werden und wir dann aber eben am Ende nicht egal wie viel Mehrheit sie im Repräsentantenhaus haben ohne weiteres für ein Amtsenthebungsverfahren,
reichen weil sie dafür eben auch eine Zweidrittelmehrheit im Senat bräuchten wenn ich mich nicht täusche aber wer weiß was der Maler da noch alles rausholt aufjedenfall Diva.
Würde er wird auf jeden Fall diesen mit dieser Situation auch gerechnet haben da ist man sich glaube ich relativ sicher also ein Plan wird er haben der aufgeht wenn wir sehen.
Ich kann es Dir nicht anders sagen als dass.
Dass wir regelmäßig das Blut in den Adern gefriert wenn ich mir angucke wie Donald Trump,
da agiert er der der feiert ein Tag nach der Wahl den Justizminister wo völlig klar war dass er den den hatte ja schon die ganze Zeit immer auf Twitter gedisst ja was auch.
Irgendwie das sind Zustände sorry stell dir mal vor irgendwie Angela Merkel,
ich würde irgendwie ihre Minister auf Twitter beschimpfen.
Also er abgesehen davon dass dass dass das ein Niveau ist auf dem man echt.
Generell nicht kommunizieren.
Wie alt war das etwa so niedrig ist und so peinlich.
Muss ich mir das jetzt wirklich vorstellen es ist nicht so schön mir das vorzustellen.
Lass dann stellt sie am besten einfach nicht vorstellen wir uns vor Donald Trump würde die also nachdem wir jetzt jahrelang sein oder oder ich glaube tatsächlich irgendwie mindestens anderthalb Jahre den,
Justizminister Jeff sessions immer Outfitter beschimpft hat hat er denn jetzt einen Tag nach der Wahl gekickt.
Wohl doch keiner besonders überrascht.
Wo genau aber es war auch klar jetzt einfach nur nicht vor der Wahl gemacht weil ihn irgendjemand gesagt hat ey pass mal auf das könnte dich noch könnte uns noch mal ein paar Stimmen kosten wenn du jetzt hier so ganz offensichtlich wieder versuchst,
die Justiz zu behindern.
Was macht als nächstes flippt aus in einer Pressekonferenz in der er mit seiner Wahlkampf.
Lüge konfrontiert wird die nämlich,
diese Karawane betrifft es gibt ja offenbar eine Karawane von einer niedrigen.
Dreistelligen Zahl von Fußgängern die,
eine niedrig dreistellige Anzahl an Fußgängern die ihr wie aus dem Süden des Kontinentes Amerika kommen und gerade wenn ich mich recht entsinne.
Genau die kommen aus von Doris und sind jetzt in die auf Höhe Mexiko oder so die haben noch ein bisschen was vor.
Die sind im Süden Mexikos.
Genau die haben doch die müssen doch Mexiko durch großes Land übrigens Max.
Großes Leid wenn du da mit dem Bus fährst bist du schon in Wien paar Tage unterwegs bis amerikanischen Größen.
Die kommen noch nicht mal mit dem Bus die kommt zu Fuß und die wurden die waren halt das große das große Thema in den USA.
Muss sagen das weiß für diese Wahlen natürlich ungünstig dass diese Menschen da.
So viel in den Medien sein konnten Trump hat behauptet
die würden finanziert werden von den Demokraten von George Soros von Sarahs weiße ein Milliardär der der diese open society foundations gegründet hat und den ganzen der irgendwie alle möglichen Liberalen Initiativen mit Millionen finanziert ne finanziert damit
mit Klingelbeutel Resten so ein paar Fußgänger wenn der Torus die finanziert hätte ne dann wären die aber mindestens nonstop geflogen wenn ich business.
Ja aber du weißt ja auch dass wenn man sagt ist von Soros finanziert ist das ja nicht eine.
Eine Behauptung er habe etwas finanziert dann ist es ein Codewort so das Codewort ist ist von den Juden finanziert,
das ist das was immer gesagt wird die AFD hat das ja in Deutschland auch drauf den Spruch und nimmer wenn sowas kommt wie die Hochfinanz und so weiter das ist halt einfach alles Codeworte die bei
der radikalisierten weißen männlichen Mehrheit von Nationalisten einfach gut ankommt und deswegen wirst du was gesagt
und dieses ganze ich meinte die diese Pressekonferenz war einfach mal wieder völlig über.
Ich bin noch ganz kurz bei diesem Thema bleiben weil da gab's ja es ging ja nur mal das Ausmaß wie also erstens hat er gesagt die wären jetzt von denen von,
der jüdischen Weltverschwörung finanziert dann hat er behauptet
unter diesen Menschen würden sich Leute aus dem mittleren und Nahen Osten befinden die beabsichtigen Terroranschläge in Deutschland in den USA zu früh.
Und sie werden alle Gewalt.
Wenn alle gewalttätig und gefährlich dann haben sie die republikanische Partei einen Wahlwerbespot gestartet wo dann noch mal ihr wie gesagt wurde diese.
Da kommt jetzt alle kriminellen da wurde ein,
Mensch gezeigt der 2014 verurteilt wurde weil er zwei Menschen getötet hatte in Sacramento eine Stadt in Kalifornien,
der,
irgendwo vor Kameras gesagt hat das einzige was ich bereue ist dass ich nicht dass ich nicht mehr als zwei getötet habe also eindeutig ein Psychopath ja,
oder ein eines schwer gestörter Mensch der eben hier eine sehr böse
Äußerung getan hat die jetzt hier politisiert wurde um dein paar Fußgänger zu diskreditieren.
Dieser Wahlwerbespot da hat sich Fox-News geweigert den zusenden weil der so rassistisch war Fox News,
die den ganzen Tag sagen aus dem Mittleren Osten kommen von von der jüdischen Weltverschwörung,
finanzierte Bolschewisten um um uns zu zersetzen oder sowas ja die die dir in den ganzen Tag nichts anderes als in diesem Fernsehspot war und selbst foxius hat gesagt hör mal kannst du es nicht was anderes schicken ist ein bisschen
bisschen hart jetzt hier Sonne und,
zu dieser Situation stellt an der Costa,
der einer der von CNN entsandten Reporter im Weißen Haus.
Dem US-Präsidenten bei einer Pressekonferenz eine Frage und sagt ja Herr Präsident wollte mal irgendwie ungefähr grob wissen sie haben ja hier von einer Invasion gesprochen ja diese,
willing Fußgänger im Süden Mexikos es ist doch keine Invasion können wir uns mal erklären wie sie dazu kommen dass das eine Invasion ist und was macht Trump.
Er geht natürlich voll auf ihn los und sag das wäre ja unerhört und was er hier überhaupt macht in der wäre ein Displays und enemy of the people das volle Programm und wird aber auch,
aber wenn man also wenn man ihnen,
zuschaut dabei vivir er sich verrenkt und verdreht und am liebsten aus dem Raum rennen möchte wieder merkt wie unheim in Demmin das ist und wer sich dann sofort
in diese Strategie der Beschimpfungen flüchtet das ist schon wirklich crazy.
Und dann kommt der Gitti die ich habe jetzt festgestellt
in der Berichterstattung wird gesagt das ist eine Praktikantin des Weißen Hauses keine Ahnung auf jeden Fall eine Frau die ein Aufgabe in dieser Situation offenbar ist oder die
ihr wie diesen Warum verwaltet ja ich keine Ahnung was ihre Positionen oder Stellung ist aber die in diesem Moment,
ihre Situation sieht dem das Mikrofon auch wieder zu entziehen und die greift dann also so nach dem Mikrofon und erhält so bisschen abwehrend die Hand,
in ihre Richtung und sag dann als sie versucht ihn das mikrofon wegzunehmen sagt er dann so excuse me Mum und versucht er noch seine Frage weiter zu stellen da wird die Situation tatsächlich so ein bisschen brenzlig weil du da jetzt natürlich,
ich meinte wenn dir das Wort entzogen wird und du jetzt in du dann dich körperlich dagegen wärst oder wird die Situation irgendwie halt richtig krass so.
Und vor allem wenn dann nicht alle Reporter in diesem Raum sofort sagen was denn hier los das der Pressekonferenz natürlich kann er seine Frage stellen das ist das eigentlich eklige in diesem Video dass die da alle sitzen und lachen
ja oder oder zumindest nicht sofort protestieren und Eingreifen der einzige Protest der im unmittelbaren kommt ist der
der Mensch der danach gefragt wird dir dann sagt tschuldigung ich muss sagen ich kenne diesen Menschen sehr gut und ist ein sehr den and Erin,
gewissenhafter und womit wohl mit guten Manieren ausgestattet haben Mensch so Reporter.
Mehr kommt da nicht und,
Trump verweist ihn also dieser Pressekonferenz und seine eigene Pressesprecherin Sarah Huckabee Sanders Twitter,
ein Video dieser dieses dieser Situation das manipuliert wurde,
in der nämlich erstens seinen Freund sein seine Worte seine verteidigen Worte gegenüber der Frau die in das Mikrofon wegnehmen möchte rausgeschnitten sind
die im lauten excuse me Madam also so ungefähr die die die die höchste Höflichkeitsform die Du einem Menschen
gegenüber bringen kannst dir gerade irgendwie dir ins Gesicht greift und das Mikrofon weg Reich und seine abwehrende Hand dir erstmal so ein Schild Schutzart ich vor sich hält und sich dann in ihre Richtung dreht diese
diese Szene ist in dem Video ganz leicht beschleunigt so dass es aussieht dass er sich eben,
dass ihm die Grenze von erhält die Hand weg und dreht sich in ihre Richtung marginal verändert ist in Richtung der schlägt die Frau weg.
Uns im inzwischen wenn ich das gerade im Deutschlandfunk noch richtig gehört habe ist sogar der Blockade den so ein rechter Blogger der diese Manipulation vorgenommen hat sogar geständig.
Du hast jetzt irgendwie die die schreien ihre Journalisten an prügeln die aus dem Pressekonferenzen und verbreiten nachher manipulierte Videos von den von den von den Zuständen dort.
Wo man fragt sich dann halt immer wieder naja wieso machen die denn das wieso Lügen sie denn die ganze Zeit und.
Weil sie damit durchkommen.
Nicht nur das.
Nicht nur weil sie damit durchkommen sondern weil es auch zeigt wir kommen mit allem durch.
Wir haben Macht über euch ihr seid nichts wir können lügen wir können uns schlecht benehmen wir können tun und lassen was wir wollen ihr seid einfach ein Stück Scheiße und wir haben jetzt hier den Hut.
Es geht sogar noch weiter ne also der Costa den hat der Trump ja schon öfter beschimpft wenn der.
Schilddrüse auch nicht irgendjemand der
Chef Korrespondent von CNN für White House Reporter also es ist jetzt nicht irgendjemand der jetzt mal zufällig kurz da war und auf dem mal rum getreten hat er ist sozusagen der Premiere Repräsentant von CNN im Kontext der Berichterstattung des Weißen Haus über das Weiße Haus.
Der übrigens jetzt schon irgendwie bei Wahlkampfauftritt von Trump als Reporter dann vor Ort war und von den dort anwesenden Menschen beschimpft wurde,
der kann seine Arbeit nicht mehr nachgehen weil diese Trump piston,
den als irgendwie Feindes Feind des Guten anstand.
Während seiner Arbeit beschimpften ähnlich wie wir es hier in Deutschland ja auch mit denen Verfassungs Freundin von der AFD,
Hellsehen nadi dann dieses Dienst dann da irgendwelche Hüte noch für aufziehen und bei der Polizei tätig sind ja,
und das sind das sind Zustände einer politischen Kultur die sehr schlecht sind und deswegen blicke ich auch unglücklich auf das oder oder nicht besonders zuversichtlich auf die Situation die wir nun,
im für die nächsten zwei Jahre in den USA haben weil Trump seine Rhetorik weiterhin darauf ausrichten wird die.
Demokraten irgendwie als obstructionist also Verhinderer und Feinde des Volkes in irgendeiner Form zu diskreditieren und zu beschimpfen und.
Es ist einfach sehr sehr sehr bedauerlich und traurig wie die politische Kultur der.
Basierten Auseinandersetzung vor unseren Augen.
Verschwindet und das war immer auch die Voraussetzungen für jegliche Grundannahmen das überhaupt eine Demokratie was eine vernünftige Staatsform ist dass das sinnvoll ist das zu tun,
das ist eine Öffentlichkeit gibt die faktenbasiert ist und dass diese Fakten auch in der Öffentlichkeit Anerkennung und Widerhall finden.
Und wenn du wenn du dein Land soweit hast dass das irgendwie deinen Präsident am laufenden Band ausrastet.
Und wirklich völlig durchschaubare politische Manöver abziehen kann dir z.b. ob das Feuern des Justizministers der eben Dienstherr von.
Der Chefermittler sister welcher der Chefermittler darf man nicht vergessen ein Ermittler ist der unter Umständen.
Übermorgen kommt er habe fertig nichts gesehen Trump ist clean das könnte ja auch sein ne.
Und all das in der unter den Augen der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet und die Menschen immer noch sagen ihr okay ist in Ordnung natürlich
dieser Maler wird dem gefährlich genial der Trump das ist erst nach der Wahl gemacht hat hätte in der Stimmen gekostet das war zu tun Fake News Fake News Fake News schön dass er endlich diesen diesen ekelhaften Reporter von CNN rausgeworfen hat der ihm immer die gemeinen Fragen stellt kann ich gut verstehen.
Das ist ja irgendwie wirklich.
Unvorstellbar und es ist fürchterlich weil das ein Schaden ist an der Kultur.
Ja ist mein das ist einfach das Gesicht des Faschismus was wir hier sehen und natürlich auch Teil dieses ganzen ganzen Strategie
er hat das als Erzieher mit Frank unterhalten haben über selber war ne also das Ziel,
der zersetzenden Kräfte ist schlicht die Zerrüttung des gesellschaftlichen Dialogs da sind sie dann halt schon sehr weit und das wird lange dauern bis das wieder gerade gebogen werden kann.
Ja du hast zum Glück behandeln wir Trump hier nur selten.
Und können uns ja dann auch in ein paar refreshing memories flüchten denn.
Der Film all creatures welcome der ja seit längerer Zeit in der Mache ist.
Nun endlich fertig und feiert gerade so seine Premieren Wochen in mehreren Kinos in Deutschland in den nächsten Wochen zu sehen.
Und hat eine ganz großartige Rezension auf SpiegelOnline bekommen die mich wirklich äußerst gefreut hat.
Vielleicht möchtest du einmal
auf den ersten Satz da der der Film all creatures welcome bringt die Welt der Hacker und Nerd selbst Technik Verden Zuschauern und er will zeigen wie vorbildlich Menschen miteinander umgehen können das doch toll,
das auch wirklich schön da freue ich mich doch über diese Rezeption der der Chaos Events die die in diesem Film eben ihren Widerhall gefunden hat.
Wobei ich den Titel so bist du verstören.
Des Artikels oder des Filmes,
der Film ist der der der Titel des Artikels ist Liebe Kinder lernt löten Dokumentation über den CCC der Tee ist irgendwie komisch gewählt vermutlich Ergebnis eines AB Test der sich besser geklickt hat oder so,
bezieht sich aber darauf dass in der in der Rezension eine Szene in dem Film gezeigt wird wo daniel Domscheit-Berg.
Mit einem Kind beim junghacker Tag
löten lernt und dann nebenbei noch so ein bisschen über Informationsfreiheit philosophiert und ja halt also der Titel dieser Rezension der sei nachgesehen wir wissen ja auch dass die,
in der Regel die Titel von anderen Leuten festgelegt werden als die die die Artikel schreiben insofern wollen wir die.
Ja was mich am meisten daran gestört dass ich für dich zehnmal gebraucht habe bis ich bemerkt habe dass er nicht steht liebe Kinder lern töten vielleicht dass ich da die falsche Schere im Kopf.
Ich meinte im Kontext der sonst bei Spiegel-Online berichteten sagten er ist Kinder lern töten auf jeden Fall irgendwie,
Steve näher als Kinder lernten umso schöner dass wir hier so ein schönes Porträt unserer Community haben welches.
Achso so schön angenommen wird er in den Rezensionen,
Termine du hattest es gerade da können wir direkt auch mal durch sans komme ein bisschen weiter runter wieder,
am 9. November also heute in Fürth am 10 und 11 aber auch noch mal am 15 dann in Hamburg am 17 in Karlsruhe am 23,
in welcher Stadt.
GPN also auch noch mal in Karlsruhe dann noch mal am 27 in Hamburg und was haben wir da am 4. Dezember in limba da jetzt fehlt mir auch noch die Stadt.
In Göttingen so da gibt's noch mehr Termine findet ihr in den Shownotes verlinkt.
Wo dieser Film wo ich diesen Film anschauen könnt ihr euch hoffentlich an das Camp 20.15 erinnert Lust macht auf Camp 20,
19 und der vielleicht auch an die vergangenen Kongresse erinnert namentlich insbesondere den Kongress 2015 und,
20/16 also den 32 und 33 C3 wenn ich das jetzt richtig gezählt habe.
Und das Linus bringt uns zu den Terminen.
Am Samstag den 7 November 2018 ist wieder der global day of Code Retreat der zeitgleich an über hundert Orten weltweit und auch in vielen Städten in Deutschland stattfindet im deutschsprachigen Raum stattfindet.
Und da geht es darum dass die Menschen einen ganzen Tag lang immer wieder einer einer Lösung für ein Problem koten in diesem Fall cornways game of life.
Und da kann man Kötter mitmachen.
Ja es geht darum sauber zu programmieren und dabei neue Leute Tools Programmiersprachen und Techniken kennenzulernen kreuzwort Report org findet ihr da ein paar Infos zu.
Sehr sauber zu programmieren sogar.
Sehr sauber sauber.
Ja wäre aber lieber Lust hat auf eine cryptoparty da gibt's in Stuttgart die nächste Gelegenheit am Samstag den 17.10 ebenfalls um 14 Uhr und wie immer
finde das in der Stadtbibliothek Stadtcafe Mate und Snacks gehen aufs Haus.
Dann gibt es am 20.11 in der Universität Heidelberg einen Vortrag unter dem Titel Freiheit Sicherheit und recht in Zeiten der Digitalisierung um 16:15 Uhr in der Aula der neuen Universität mit
just Rudi und weißt du selten in Heidelberg bin habe ich gedacht ich wenn das mal.
Warum nimmst das nicht Sicherheit und Recht und Freiheit.
Ey weißt du eigentlich kalt und Recht und digital Safari egal kommt drauf an was hinten rauskommt.
Ja okay
so und wir hatten schon fast erwähnt als wir über all creatures welcome gesprochen haben denn das mit dir dann auch gezeigt im Rahmen der Glühwein Programmier Nacht also known as GPN 18,5 wo sollte es anders sein
als in Karlsruhe wo ja auch schon die früher hast GPN stattfindet und das ganze in schattin.
HfG Hochschule für Gestaltung also am selben Ort wo auch die andere GPN stattfindet.
Ist ja auch nur die Acten 18,5.
Das ganze Abend 23 November bis zum 25 November 2008.
Dann am 24 November Samstag um 13 Uhr in Magdeburg wird unter dem Motto unheimlich sicher
zur Demonstration gegen die Innenministerkonferenz aufgerufen Protest gegen die neuen Polizeigesetze polizeiaufgabengesetz für staatliche Überwachung Repression gegen Fußballfans
und die sogenannten ankerzentren los geht's um 13 Uhr am Magdeburger Hauptbahnhof.
Und für die Freunde der Rechtspolitik gibt's den Tag der Rechtspolitik in 2018 der findet statt am 29 November am Donnerstag an der Universität in Frankfurt
unter dem Motto alles frei Regulierung der Daten und Inhalte im Netz wird hier aus
Polizei Sicht über Vorgänge der Netzpolitik diskutiert und vorgetragen.
Muss noch gesagt wenn das ist Frankfurt am Main ist für so eine so eine Wessi zentrische Sicht immer bei Frankfurt einfach davon auszugehen dass es das am Main ist.
Das stimmt das eine korrekte Einwand.
Aber jetzt wo du Deutscher bist Tim kannst du dir auch so schöne Wessi Allüren durchaus mal gönnen.
Ich sag mir wenn sie alt werden können.
Wir einfach mal Frankfurt sagen welches Frankfurt.
Bin ja nicht in der gesamtdeutscher geworden.
Gesamtdeutsche.
Ja ich habe ja mit der Teilung nichts.
Ich war gar nicht hier.
Als dritte weiß nicht ob du da nicht doch die.
Na ja immer diese Ausländer jajajaja.
Cindewittchen nie richtig integriert werden ich werde immer Witze über dich machen uns nach an Gruppe.
Na ja, nicht sooo.
Ja das war die Sendung.
Was war die Sendung.
Immer wieder schön schlechte Laune.
Verbreitet.
Super.
So möchtest auch du wolltest doch nicht anders.
Jetzt schon nächste Woche haben wir auch wieder vielleicht ein paar gute Nachrichten ich bin ja mal es gibt auch eine gute Nachricht bei nächste Woche ich bin da gut ich bin da guter Dinge,
vielleicht fällt mir eine ein ansonsten über eine die für diese Woche weggelassen haben wir zuviel gute Nacht.
Mal schauen.
Ich würde dann jetzt ganz kurz die Zeit nutzen ein bisschen Dank loszuwerden weil ich das in den letzten Sendungen übersprungen habe das heißt da hat sich ein bisschen etwas
angesammelt und ich weiß dass es nächste Woche auch noch mal was kommen wird an Dank aber jetzt erstmal mein Dank an
Christian Daniel Lukas Jens Sascha Dittrich Harald und andres.
Gut so und ja ich danke vor allem allen Dauer Beauftragten der Metaebene.
Also mich Dauer beauftragter hier.
Lov na ja alle bedauer beauftragenden.
Auftragenden er.
Anrufen wünsche euch trotz alledem eine schöne Woche und sofern süßen Wassers umsonst.
Ciao ciao.